I guess we're like to begin its with
your early life to understand who you
were as a young man coming of age as a
Muslim in England
spit out at home that is awesome so no
what do you mean what age you want me to
start wherever you want to start okay
well wherever you feel the beginnings at
the beginning okay I'll just cover my
quickly I'm from the beginning in brief
I was born in Entebbe Uganda my father
is Pakistani my mother is Nubian her
background is that the grandfather the
great grandfather something that came
from southern Sudan and then I'm settled
in northern Uganda and at eight years
old I came to the UK with my mother and
my brother and sister and then I was
schooled here primary school secondary
school and college I was doing fine in
secondary school and in college college
I know the u.s. to have a different
system college doesn't mean university
it's just two years before you go to
university here do many memories of your
early life in Uganda yeah yeah it's just
I remember throwing things at the
monkeys and when I'm going to school and
the monkeys throw things back I remember
the tadpole was in water
I remember the plant way and when you
touch it then it kind of groups closes
up in groups I remember being scared of
the chameleons I think I remember I
remember my mother sitting with my
sister
our out in the front of the house and in
a black member I'm approaching from
behind and I said to mom I said mommy
snake and then I remember later on the
drunk neighbor he was drunk and at the
same time he was he was having a batter
with a snake so in the distance
I remember the locusts
we went out and it was near night and
then we're collecting the locusts I
think it was locusts or whatever I was
in safe I mean wait that was nice yeah I
remember I remember stealing my friend's
toy ever think there's a Laurie my
mother told me to take it back and I had
to take back and say sorry which was
very shameful and then and I remember a
boy coming over and he had one of these
these kind of camera things that tourist
type things that you pay and then you
you look into it and then you see images
like the Eiffel Tower and things like
that and yeah what was the town like
where you were living Entebbe
I mean was it was I just remember it
dusty like but he was okay I don't I
don't remember much too much about it
but cuz you know I came here when I was
eight so those of my early early
memories but you know it was sunny I
just remember that sunny and you know it
was okay
where did you shuttle in English Croydon
yeah do you remember much about that
neighborhood or aisle Croydon I've lived
Croydon two decades I've I've been here
two decades so yeah I know it it's where
I'm from in London yeah I mean in terms
of memories of them I mean I went to
school here Primary School secondary
school college and that's about it
do you remember what it was like making
the switch from from living
I guess was a I was eight years old so
it's just not a big issue the second
thing is because you think that kind of
maybe racism or racial aspect or being
different people would t treat you
differently it wasn't an issue because
in Uganda because my father's Pakistani
I didn't belong to a tribe so and I look
different so coming over here and then
being different as well in school my
school second a primary school and
secondary school majority white so there
was very few black people but it wasn't
an issue for me because um I was always
different do you have any memories of
facing any racism at the time
no because when I came there was this
whole thing and it was he surprised me
that in primary school and secondary
school the the children themselves my
peers you know had understood that
racism is wrong and they did they really
did not they're not like racists they
don't like people who racist in general
and then they knew it was wrong so you
know it wasn't something that I faced on
a frequent frequent basis what kind of a
student were you I I don't know maybe
it's cause of Africa my genes I'm the
kind of student that does my own work
I'm self-motivated and I think my mother
instilled into me that imports of
education and learning and maybe it's a
genetic thing as well that's where and
that's why I can I incline so I did I
did okay I mean I wasn't the brightest I
wasn't the best I wasn't getting a stars
over the time but you know I was doing
fine where did you go to college or
university Oh to university I actually
went to university after coming back
from Guantanamo oh yeah
I don't know I'm the Oh College let's go
to your for your education before water
okay
College was John Ruskin yeah
turning to do what I was doing my
a-levels
I kind of like I said I was going
through a crisis yeah I started off with
four levels which is unusual at that
time and I don't know I was doing our
thesis I say to myself I was setting
myself up for four because I guess I
don't know why but I said I start off
with four levels I think it was
chemistry physics maths was a biology
you know electronics and then I dropped
one just chemistry and then mass I
wasn't doing too well and then then I
took up general studies and basically I
just kind of scraped through and when he
came to college I barely made it
what did you have any idea of what you
were studying for what's your future
would be yeah it comes from Uganda for
me I had this thing that about welfare
that because we want you know our
background is poverty oh I had this
thing that welfare was important and but
I had this idea I was just a kid that
you know if you can do robots if robots
can do the work then people have more
leisure time so if you know so I had
this whole thing about science and
electronics and electronic engineering
and then I wanted to go into neural
networks artificial neural networks
because that was the next generation of
computers and that kind of thing so
that's what I was looking to go into
when you were growing up in what what
sense did you did you have of the the
Uganda that you left behind did you
gather go back there did you did you did
you stay in touch with relatives did you
know the I think there was because I'm
growing up so I'm going from 8 to about
1617 and because were immigrants in this
country there was restrictions on travel
and so forth and not going back and etc
in order to get your British citizenship
so I think that kind of restricted us
from going back and basically when we
went back in 1999 so I was like 18 and
think maybe 19 I think 18 in terms of
keeping in touch I don't know why but it
just doesn't seem that that side of the
family I don't know what happened but we
never kept in touch my mother keeps in
touch
obviously her brothers and sisters my
uncles and so forth but in terms of us
there wasn't any real connection with
you again the community here I mean in a
small way that your friends and things
like that and you see each other
sometimes not in a real meaningful way
you mentioned crushes on over time was
not a religious person yeah yeah okay um
the system in this country let me think
okay primary school I mean my mother who
used to tell me um that I was Muslim and
but then she told me that Arab as well
because us Muslim was just a joke like
you know because if you the Arabs are
Muslims so if you're Muslim Europe and
you know I remember that in Uganda she
did tell me one time to go into the
mosque and and do like everyone else so
I went in and and I I mean I didn't know
what I was doing so I saw someone
washing their feet I washed my feet I
was very young before 8 years old and
then I went into the prayer hall and I
saw people like praying and then they
were praying not the obligatory prayer
because it's kind of standard I
systemized obligated to favor their own
praying their own individual prayers I
was confused so I managed to do a
frustration but that's about it and I
remember that so when coming coming to
the UK and in primary school
I had this idea that you know I was
Muslim but I didn't know what that what
that meant and I remember one of the
memories that I remember in primary
school I showed him how to prostrate and
they they laughed I was just a kid I'm
not in a bad way not in the bad way it's
just like I was I was playing with them
as well but you know when you hit
puberty as it were you know you told
your Muslim but there's nothing there
isn't it there's no there's no
definition of what Muslim is were you
know
what does it mean and so in secondary
school I was a theist and that went
through across through the whole of
secondary school in about 16 a friend of
the family he was young in his late 20s
he died of a brain tumor
so I didn't think it affected me that
much I mean it affected me but you know
I carried on 16 I had my own GCSEs and
there's a your qualifications you get
after secondary school so you have to
study for them etc so I had to revise
for those I revised and then I did I
mean I was happy with my result from
well actually no I wasn't I would have
been happy with my result from the GCSE
he's but for some reason when I did get
the result it didn't mean anything to me
sorry yeah that was a big blow because
it's like you know I from 11 years over
to sixteen five years I studied just to
get these results and these would lead
onto a levels and these would lead onto
University and he's really done to my
career and that was the plan but for
some reason I get the results and
they're good results I'm happy with
those reside have been happy resources
results but oh but I wasn't so the thing
is as a discount in juncture when you
leave secondary school you go to college
secondary school they teach your
children like children college you're
treated like an adult immediately so
with that kind of freedom it kind of you
know like tripped me up in a way so I
didn't know what to do so I had to think
about my future what was my purpose in
life and so forth etc so I said to
myself you know ok they say my purposes
in life is making money so I'll make
loads of money but the thing was that
death death if I die no matter how much
money I made it it won't stay with me so
I'm this I'm the type of person that you
know if I if I do something I like it to
last I don't like things being taken
away from me once I've worked hard and
and you know I feel that I've earned
them so I said women but the same thing
you died or whatever whatever I thought
of you know the culmination of it was
that it just meant nothing and I mean
I'm one of those I was one of those
people who kind of would visualize
success so you know I'd be successful
one thing or another thing I mean I
liked martial arts you visualize
you know ice and martial artists and so
forth but every time you come to that
peak there was always that kind of
depressive drop that is nothing after
that and that kind of really threw me so
I started asking questions about you
know what is the purpose of life and so
forth and you know what I was taught in
school is that when you have a question
you're gonna look look in the books and
get the answer so I went to the local
bookshop and I said look in the
spiritual section and I picked up a few
books and then when I picked up one was
Zen Buddhism so I think of Zen Buddhism
and I start reading about Zen Buddhism
and symbolism had some answers to to
those questions but they weren't the
right answers but I said you know I
didn't know they weren't right the right
answers this was great I thought to
myself these are the answers
I'm karma and the cycle of life and good
deeds and bad deeds what were some of
the answers that Zen Buddhism seemed to
offer
okay the UM the the issue is it's all
about what what is the purpose of life
so why do you die so what happens after
you die so Zen Buddhism on I gave an
answer to why you know what happens to
you after you die you know there has to
be something that happens it can't just
be like the cruel world and injustice
isn't and that's it and then the second
thing was Zen Buddhism gave an answer to
words why is it good people bad things
happen to good people that's that's an
important question I think a lot of
atheists have trouble with that then it
was like you know I guess not really an
answer but it proposed then Buddhism
that you know you should do good deeds
and the reason why you should do good
deeds you know and then you know I guess
that does that those were the answers
you know in a way that yeah I guess I
was looking for and it also proposed I
like the story of the Buddha there the
first
I mean Buddha's are tight was no actual
name but the first but because he gave
up according to the story of princely
riches in order to go to live a hard
life in order to find
the truth to relieve all creation of of
suffering so his thing was creation so
and that kind of resonated with my
welfare kind of think so there's this
kind of shift um became disillusioned
with machines bringing he bringing
happiness to mankind and giving that
welfare and then you start looked
elsewhere and religion was kind of the
thing that kind of filled that void
okay so okay I mean Croydon and I've got
a book on Zen Buddhism and from the book
shop so I consider myself a Zen Buddhist
and then I have two made up meditate so
I'm trying to meditate and I'm trying to
sit and half lotus position is hurting
and then when you meditate you know
supposed to think good or bad you know
have supposed to have any thoughts so
it's not really working out because you
know my legs are hurting and Zen
Buddhism is it's kind of like the
meditation is not going the way I
thought it would so I cut it short
basically I came to the conclusion Zen
Buddhism wasn't a religion for a
practical life that's that's my
conclusion that you had to be in a
monastery and you had to be away from
from real life to to me to practice it
so I kind of put it aside in terms of
the meditation etc but that the aspect
of welfare like for instance if you walk
you shouldn't step on the ants and
things like that you should show
compassion to the creation you know
those kind of remained with me I started
working in Oxfam charity shop um because
I what originally was because I thought
my store of bad days was more than my
store of good tea so I should do some
charity so it kind of even it up so I
started working Oxfam and doing some
charity there you know voluntarily and
and that kind of thing but obviously
than this that that question was still
there you know what is the purpose of
life and Zen Buddhism didn't answer
those questions so in secondary school
if I just jump back a slightly we get I
think assemblies when when the class
just sits and he someone comes in to
books to you and one time there were
some Christians that came to talk to us
and they gave us a copy of the New
Testament unfortunately some of the
other students they didn't really show
any much respect for it I was spitting
on the jumping on and kicking it and so
forth I I took my own back and I put it
in a shelf I don't know why I had this
kind of you know sense that if I'm not
gonna read it at least just kind of show
some respect
and it stayed there I mean at least two
years
this must have been 14 when they came so
it's more than two years actually I'm 17
so I got the inclination to read the
Bible so so because it was a New
Testament I got myself a copy of the
there's a full Bible Old and New
Testament and I decided to try to read
it from page to page
so from cover to cover I didn't get far
I got I got to the Ark of the Covenant
and his dimensions and I decided to read
the New Testament which was kind of more
it's a bit easier to read because the
Old Testament is a lot of detail
yes it's very grinding and then then
Kosovo was happening at that time so I'm
reading revelations as well so I'm
putting two two two and two together and
getting two minutes so I thought it was
over this is World War three and then um
but Christianity didn't it didn't make
sense to me I was thinking about it and
those things that I didn't kind of agree
with so that kind of didn't last long it
didn't last long with the Christianity
but I mean I mean I did I got myself a
cross and you know like but it was not
so much the image of Christ as my savior
was more that back to that suffering
thing again and the welfare there he was
an image of someone suffering and for a
good cause in a way so but I guess the
Chris you know the Christianity is in
Arsenal and then then it's it's things
got hard upon me really
it's got it to cut a long story short
you know do that oh sorry sorry about
the longer okay all right okay so
basically you know atheism right now is
winning and I'm seventeen years old so
admittedly what do you mean like a
season you just don't believe in God
finish
you don't believe there's a higher power
you don't you just you just believe I
guess you believe you Humanity is the
highest power there is no no I don't
know you don't you don't believe in in
God or any any anything supernatural in
a way that's that's atheism wait when
you say winning the battle for your soul
I knew there was a third truth out there
I was searching for the truth but you
know I was and Buddhism wasn't and
Christianity wasn't it and it was just
like you know I couldn't find it so
obviously if you're searching for
something that you know you don't it's
not like I knew it's like I read it in a
book somewhere and I forgot what the
book was and I were to search from the
book you know he's just something innate
in yourself that you know that the truth
is out there but sometimes you've maybe
become disillusioned maybe think
yourself you're fooling yourself by that
so that's the kind of battle those I
think that I knew that reader truth was
out there but it was only more of a hope
and obviously hope can can can rise and
fall but it was just hope because I
didn't I didn't have anything definite I
hadn't seen it it wasn't a flicker I
hadn't someone told me about everybody's
approx over there I don't know I had to
go search for it was just something
within myself they came from out from
within myself telling me that there is a
truth early and you know but you know
when you become disillusioned and you
start losing hopes and mr. atheism and
with atheism the world just becomes a
very harsh place and so well 17 let's
just say I became suicidal and I did try
to kill myself because I thought to
myself you know this is there's no point
in life the pain of living was well to
my to my thinking the pain of living was
more than if you ended you
as if there's nothing then it's just
zero isn't it and you can get away from
the pain but you don't experience the
pleasure of life so I was so sorry you
have friends who shared this it's
strange it's just that it's during
secondary school I don't know what
happened I mean I had colleagues but not
real from no real friends I don't know
why is what you know it's just kind of
there was always this juncture yeah you
know I don't I don't know why but I
don't I don't kind of relate to people
in a very kind of close way so there was
this disjunction but um when he wants to
leave secondary school I mean that's the
life you've known for five years and you
could rob from child to tornado I'm
young right up and I don't and then you
come to college then they say you're
gonna make those friends all over again
but if you don't have if you're
questioning your purpose in life then
you don't your interests and who you are
and what you're about then you're not
one of if you're not settled within
yourself how can you find friends who
have the somewhat similar values and a
similar outlook when you don't know your
own values or your outlook that's oh
yeah
so really like I said atheism was kind
of winning and then but it was
necessarily I was broken down so things
had to become hard until I cracked and
basically there was I just remember
being in my room and then saying oh god
help me
now this is very strange because you
know before I didn't believe in God and
with Zen Buddhism you don't believe in
God you don't believe in God but you
know I asked God to help me and then but
then I got angry and because it helped
him come immediately so I got angry at
and I was like karma was a smash
something of something that ever you
know I was a young teenager so you know
whatever and so it was like two suicide
attempts one was a spur another one was
paracetamol and then but obviously
didn't you know I didn't kill myself
because I'm here
and then um my third suicide attempt was
to it was it was silly but I wasn't
thinking straight
um because I spoke to someone and they
said how you know go travel with things
like that
so it wasn't a suicide attempt the first
time I tried it I went to Scotland as
far north as I could and I said I'm just
gonna make my way down south again and
then um if I have to walk it off to walk
it so you know it's just kind of one of
those things that you know I guess I had
to get away and just walked actually
tried to find meaning in my life and
then yeah I managed to make it because
there was a lorry driver who gave me a
lift and then he liked my sign due south
because there was a program called do
South with a Canadian and a horse and
and sorry I copied the name and put it
on the side of my backpack and he liked
my sign so he took me half of the way
and then he dropped me at a park and I
know some other guy who was a horse he
did something with horses or something
he took me a part of the way and Ernie
he paid for my ticket train ticket home
and then I sent him a check you know to
cover the costs afterwards I might have
managed to do that and then but my third
suicide attempt was I said to myself
right that's it I'm gonna just go and
I'm gonna travel East Europe and then
just go across and I'm aiming for Japan
where I don't think I'm gonna make him
we're gonna die on the way so that's
what I did I just I just went to Europe
from my mentor said in this book yeah
yeah I don't remember what what do you
think of the way in which he presented
you at that point I'm okay with it he
mentioned that I read the book for that
it was a long time ago so just watching
but you met someone in Switzerland oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's the story I guess I told him why
I don't remember that part in the book
so but I was long time since I read it
so yeah I'm so that's it so I went to
France and I remember going through Lyon
I wasn't thinking straight at a time I
was just like just just walking just so
how old were you at this point I must
have been eighteen eighteen yeah so I'm
just I'm just walking and I'm I'm
sleeping rough I'm sleeping on park
benches and you know and I'm the trees
and just just going and all I remember
is one time I decided that I was gonna
walk more of the day so a greater
distance because what I was doing I was
just walking to one town and I'm staying
there and then sleeping over and walking
to another town so I thought let me just
walk further because you know there's no
point me just sitting I'm just staring
at staring whatever in a town whatever
not doing anything in there and then the
the back of my Hill was got cut because
blistered at one time so I decided to
catch trains and then I ended up in
basically I ended up in Croydon ago and
croizon ago I remember because I was
crossing one board in another just
crossing over and it says I crossed over
so many times they got used to me so
they just waved me fast they wouldn't
look at my passport but I ended up and
croizon a gun and some guy he spoke
English and he said oh if you're looking
for the refugee camp it's over there I
said oh thank you but I was I was making
my way to Italy I didn't say that to him
I was just that's what I was waiting
making my way and then um then it's like
okay my memories a bit I don't know
whether made this trip twice or or once
I think that that time I decided to walk
again because I think the wounds of my
on my back on my leg and then let me
think
yeah I think I decided to walk again
because the wounds on back and why my
kind of hills were kind of getting
better I think I kind of rested him a
bit and so you know I made my way and I
followed the path and then what happens
is you have pavement sidewalk and then
and then it just becomes grass again and
then I looked at it and I started
walking and in a lorry went past and it
just reminded me of that journey that I
was doing before because you know it's
just loud
hot air turbulence things are there and
I thought to myself I don't want to
really go through this again yeah you
know it's hard enough doing it once I'm
gonna have to go back to this again so I
turned round and I thought I'll try the
refugee camp so I just remember walking
up a hill and it was a sunny day and all
during this time you know because it had
been hard it hadn't been easy sleeping
rough it's been really hard and this
must have been a week of this I had said
to me you know I'd be praying to God oh
god help me God help me God help me and
then you know a voice within myself said
do you really do you really believe in
God so I thought to myself this is
strange where am I asking myself this
and then then the voice said again do
you really believe in God and I said yes
of course and I feel that now and I felt
I think then and you know a few months
after is that you know some people and
he mentions it in the Quran there's some
people like when they're stranded on a
ship and the waves are kind of battering
the shipment is likelihood that they're
gonna die they ask God for help but once
they're on shore then they forget that
they ask God for help and they forget
God so I felt at that time I was
affirming to myself that you know I'm
not gonna go back and I'm not gonna deny
that and whatever affirmed at that point
in time
so I got to refugee camp i I was open I
gave him my British passport I'm
expecting me today I've expecting them
to slam the door on my face the guy
calls me in and I'm thinking okay what
was this strange and like me and so I'm
in the refugee camp and I think I was
there for a week and I gave my dick
invitation attention to the back of my
heel you know I got food etc and while
they were checking my
my paper papers and checking the past
was genuine I guess it cetera and there
I met a Kashmiri and he was you know
trying out his English so he told me
about a law and he told me about I'm
saying bismillah and like in the name of
love we eat he told me about Pakistan
and you know Kashmir and you know you
know that he had over there and he told
me about you know saying how low a no
quota Davila like there's no strength
and power except strength of power from
law if you're in trouble
on things like that so he told me that
so before they're not affirmed you know
I believe in God and then he just kind
of confirmed to me just informed me who
my God was nice and long and my religion
is Islam and then so basically the I'm
the refugee camp they turn around and
tell me you know have to leave if I
don't gonna imprison me so I've just
signed his favour if I wanna go I signed
a paper and you know took my passport
and then I basically I was you know III
I left and then I made my way to Zurich
where I called my mom and then I asked
her to transfer some money over and then
I caught her Eurostar and I was I was
back at home you were not mugged and
capito you're such a very much okay okay
I'll admit it the mugging incident is
not I had to you know ask for some
reason to account for certain things
going missing because I I had this thing
that I wasn't gonna turn back so I got
rid of some stuff in the garbage I think
it was my car and my my my debit card
and then in order to account for it with
it to the bank I told him yeah I got
mugged and I was I wasn't mugged no I
was not mugged well yeah
you came back now you're okay okay the
next step is um so you know coming back
I was praying to Allah saying you know a
lot get me back home and I'll read the
Quran you know all right if he if he got
me back home hurry the Quran so
obviously I come home and my mother is
there and then she kind of asked me what
what I was doing what I'd gone cuz I
didn't told him where I was or what I
was up to etc I kind of answered
evasively and then and then I said oh
mom can I read your Quran because she
had the copy from my aunt had given her
coffee because of backgrounds mustard
and it was a translation meaning Quran
Abdullah Yusuf Ali it used to be in the
living room it was just there and then
you know it wasn't really read um so I
said I'm gonna read you around she was
surprised she said yeah so I started
reading Quran and then um then I
considered myself Muslim and then I had
to learn then how to pray so so my aunt
because she she she her backgrounds
Muslim I went to her and you know there
was a family friend and then so he was
Sunni and then my aunt said you know you
should learn Arabic as well so go to
this guy which yeah so then so I'm a new
Muslim and I'm going to listen me and
he's telling me one thing and I'm going
to the Arabic lesson of this year and
he's telling me another thing so okay
now now I'm getting a bit confused this
is all in London this is all in London
the thing is yeah it was a I'm becoming
confused because they're saying
different things and as a new Muslim I I
believe that you know all Muslims were
you know we all fought as one we prayed
as one we acted as one all the same I
didn't know these differences I'm coming
across this divide Shiah and Sunni so
basically
okay dokay that they came a certain
issue I asked I asked this year I asked
a Sunni Anastos yeah I said something
and then the shower basically guy gave
me an answer he said oh mercy we live in
a modern world etc or whatever I didn't
feel comfortable with the answer because
you know I thought to myself I didn't
become Muslim in order to just go back
to the way I was before and you're
telling me that we live in a modern
world and that's what I have to do so
that was one thing that kind of you know
I thought it was a bit iffy with this
years interpretation of thing and the
second thing I was going to a bookshop
you know Islamic bookshop in in in the
in the mosque and I picked up a book on
on death and the Hereafter and I was
reading that and in there it was one one
part that said anyone who curses the
Companions of the Prophet Muhammad Allah
mentioned in amongst the Angels and
grant him peace and anyone who listens
to them you know what would be cursed or
something bad will happen to them so
this is the shower there they cursed the
Companions of fulfillments awesome so I
read I read it and I was kind of dubious
because I thinking to myself you know
you know I didn't know what to think
so for some reason the book couldn't get
out of my mind because I didn't buy it
at that time and then like a week later
something like that one and bought it
and on the bus I was flicking through
and he came to the same page and came to
the same impart anyone who curses the
Companions was a problem you know
something's gonna be bad if you yeah if
you actually even if you don't curse but
you're listening to it so I thought to
myself I'm not gonna take the risk
I'm not going to that sure again so
that's how I became something yeah but
then how did you learn Arabic okay um I
didn't Arabic has been a struggle for me
for a long time it's you know the Shia
he when I went to him he was teaching a
high level he wasn't starting from the
basics and because I was kind of an
adult he didn't put me in with the kids
class so he said you know if you just
hang around
you know stay and maybe you pick up
something on the way and then we'll
start with lessons again and then you
know then you can pick up from there and
because they were in advance so the best
I could do was just copy what he was
writing in the board and hope that later
on our understanding which kind of gave
me practice with my writing and the
Arabic script but nothing else could let
him understand any of it and then yeah
so but I guess he saw it as an
opportunity to kind of interrupt
generate me and turn me into a sure
so you chosen the sunni path what next
then I learned how to pray and then I
learned how to pray and then the thing
is when you become Muslim there's is
like the first six months is like a
honeymoon period so it's very um you
know you feel your faith is is very high
your your your your chest is expanded
and you know you're kind of easily
touched by certain things I remember
reading the book of the narrations of
the Prophet SAW cinnamoned you know when
there was a battle over hood and the
prophet Moses in him was was struck in
the face and you know he lost a tooth
the thing is the Prophet Muhammad SAW
said him that any pain we feel a huge
feel double it was the thing that he got
a double reward so you get it will feel
double any pain if also if you had a
fevered have doubled the fever of of a
normal normal person so you know being
in that state to know six months reading
that you know it will bring you to tears
because you know you're thinking were
these people doing this is approximate
hummus awesome he's being struck in the
face like this and he lost the truth he
was bleeding you know you're touched by
those things but after six months then
you know the thing is when you become
Muslim when you say I believe you want
to be tested it's not just about
affirming it and that's it you have to
show that you were true to your word and
then you know after six months and the
test came so I you know I decided to set
my life kind of straight again I've got
a job with macro is part-time which is a
wholesalers just stacking shelves and so
forth
and but I felt that you know
I was still in Croydon my life was still
going you know I still walking the same
streets you know I'd walk the same
streets and I and I'll think to myself
you know they haven't changed this to
the streets are the same the people
haven't changed but it's me that's
changed and you know I find it very I
found it very hard to kind of live my
life you know basically I felt my faith
was was new and it was very tender and
and it could easily be washed away if I
just carry on walking the same streets
and living the same kind of life in the
same place as as I was doing but I came
to to learn of Finsbury Park mosque and
and you know you know sheikh abu hamza
and so i decided to attend some of those
friday sermons because i was in the
South quadrant so it's very hard to go
to friends of EPOC it's a long distance
go from South East and in your way
through central London and you go back
up north in something so I started
attending some sermons there and then it
was I think Ramadan so Ramadan then
there was some issue about because the
mosque was run by volunteers generally
so there was some issue about security
there was no security at night and they
were worried because of mas alleged he
was taken over by force there was there
was there was worried that the people
that was taken over from they will come
back and take it over by force something
like that there was some nonsense for
politics happening before I came so
there had to be security for the person
doing security was alleged not to be
doing the security in there in the way
they should do so they kind of got upset
by it
and so I said to myself let me help out
are you doing anything myself I thought
I was just gonna help out for I don't
know like during the end of Ramadan or
something like that and to everything
when go back to normal
but I ended up staying there for I think
a year so I lived in Finsbury Park
mosque part of it was that I think you
know my family at home because before
its time affair with my family at home
the change wasn't really accepted and
you find this a lot with some
become a Muslim that they're not really
accepted by their own family members
this is this goes way back to the day
one of our history you know your family
would disown you
I'm not saying my family disowned me but
they didn't I I father didn't accept me
and so I went somewhere where I felt
some kind of acceptance and I was
friends with part mosque yeah so yeah so
I was living in the mosque our security
making sure no one came rate rated most
from the other people that was taking
over from don't did anybody try to hit
the mosque oh no no no we just had some
some unfortunately some crazy some
people were kind of a bit not straight
in the head jumping the wall and running
through a back door and suffered I mean
they live there they stayed there but we
had this policy that after certain how
he you come you can't be coming and then
expecting the door to be open and things
that are security reasons and then they
were jump so out kind of corner them and
give him a hard talking to but let them
go because you know they're gonna do it
again that kind of thing but nothing
much happened have another so it was
good it was good her I didn't have to
get involved in any altercations or
anything about that
yeah so Finn's report mosque okay
there's this whole thing about
Afghanistan being the Islamic Emirate of
Afghanistan now the thing is I think
this is poorly understood country is not
only Islamic country on this is Sharia
is applied across it it doesn't matter
how many Muslims there in that country
they could be majority nor Muslim is a
matter whether which law is applied
across it so the only country in the
world at that time that was an Islamic
state was Afghanistan because the
Taliban belong Sharia law so every other
Muslim is just a Muslim country meaning
no they don't apply Sharia yeah there
are no flat Sharia law in the way I mean
this year they have a very different
interpretation of they don't know and
they don't accept a lot of narrations of
from the Prophet Muhammad SAS on him
because of their kind of animosity to
certain companions around the first
month or so and then therefore the their
lower kind of is skewed
very different way so the only place was
an Islamic Emirate of Afghanistan and it
was this whole thing about Hitler Hitler
is to emigrate for the sake of your
religion in Finsbury Park this was a big
thing you know moved to Afghanistan the
Islamic Emirate of Afghanistan at that
time I'd been living in the mosque and
as a recluse because I found it very
hard to live to go out into their
society my faith was new and it felt
like that if I got back into society I
got a job et cetera
you know I'll slowly lose it so I was
worried that that would happen I mean I
tried to get a job but I said to myself
you know there's very few options in
terms of jobs for someone who Trond
wants to practice their religion and
we've come a road sweeper there's no
point being arrogant about it I'll sweep
I'll sweep the road at least then you
know like you know I just I don't get
into business about for instance you
work like with macros um they were okay
at the beginning and then they started
to ask me to work in the meat section
and then you have to deal with pork and
alcohol and it just became silly you
know they say you end up having and
getting into that so I thought road
sweeper sweeping the roads you can't get
in too much trouble doing that but you
know the guy said oh I was silly because
I was frank to him I said you know like
you know I'll do the job I'm gonna have
to pray sometimes but I'll pray on the
streets I said you know pre ministry
won't take long five minutes but he said
no if you're working for a team then
you're gonna be gonna be delayed and a
lot of nonsense so he didn't it didn't
it didn't take me as a road sweeper so I
couldn't get a job as a road sweeper so
what could I do so I said to myself you
know I'm gonna have to get out I'm gonna
have to bail out that's it so so I
jumped onto the Hitler project and then
yeah yeah so I jumped on the Hitler
project and then um this was November
2000 so I left for the Islamic Emirate
of Afghanistan and at this point you're
I think I'm 2019 yeah I think I'm 20
yeah
what's your Afghanistan yes what were
your first impressions of my first
impressions I don't know for some reason
I'm not I'm type of person who kind of
if I move from one kind of scenario to
another at least when I was younger I
would accept it really I don't know
whether much how it was just the way I
am so yeah it's it's not something big
but you know it was it was nice I mean I
didn't cry there's no kind of I mean I
wasn't shocked by anything or that kind
of thing it was just it was just like
it's a different different country and
it knows it so I don't remember any kind
of special memories about my first going
there yeah if you know if you only known
his security in a way you don't you
don't kind of appreciate it until it's
gone
and the thing is with Islamic Emirate of
Afghanistan I I didn't realize how much
kind of security and peace I had that my
values and you know the person I am and
where I want to be and what I want to be
doing was there until I was taken to
Montana and the stark contrast really
and he kind of showed me what I'd lost
and and it's something that pains me
today because you know I guess regret is
the worst thing in life and you know III
really regret not actually appreciating
when I had then because I don't have it
now and it burns me you know her yeah so
um yeah I spent most of our time in
Kandahar and the thing is with
Afghanistan I kind of expected and I
wasn't I'm wrong in my expectation that
you know my values and would be upheld
it was Muslim
country I was happy in that regard but I
also accepted the people who would
accept us and I thought it's gonna be
kind of kind of like a homecoming the
way the brothers that unknown brothers
in will come and it will be appreciated
by the society and will be accepted
within a society we get jobs who marry
who live as Muslims in Islamic Emirate
of Afghanistan but unfortunate that was
in the way
the Afghans considered us foreigners but
it was more like the the middle-aged
ones the the older ones the one that's
at scene that Russian jihad the ones
that had seen the Arabs come and fight
and die and bleed lose limbs sacrifice
alongside them when they saw you they
did they appreciate it they did they
came they greeted you warmly they refer
to you as a traveler and said to you you
know pray for me they they really it's
like they saw something and it was it
was something from the experience in
their past but unfortunately the younger
generation the late 20s early early 30s
they just saw you as a form and what are
you doing in this country
can you remember an episode of that kind
of interaction
yeah I'm we went to the mosque and then
the local mosque and mene mene was some
of my brothers we prayed there and then
one of the Afghans he spoke some English
he came and he said what are you doing
here just think we just came to pray to
the mosque you know like issue so what
are you doing here you came you came to
kill Afghans that's what you came for to
kill Afghans I know you came to kill
Afghans it's like so one of the other
brothers he said you know you for
carrying let us keep on saying I will
take you to the Taliban and they were
interrogate you and then he said no no
no no he said forgive Allah forgives
forgive you know you're forgiven brother
but where'd you get that idea from but
unfortunately that's their kind of you
know just that's the mentality and you
know the raised or raise prices on you
in the shops and the taxi driver would
raise prices on you and so forth he
wouldn't charge you the Afghan
rate and things they did I thought you
were kind of rich you weren't you and
you never part of the society I'm one
time I wanted to get married I asked
someone and he was blunt he said you
know we don't marry our women to you to
people like you that was it you know
there was no there's no inquiry it was
nothing it was just blunt so in a way it
was it was a very it's troubling because
here in the UK I mean I can get a job I
can I can get by society you know in
that regard in the everyday kind of
daily thing but the law of this country
and upholding my values and he said to
me as equal citizen in this country is
not he's not there but over there the
Sharia my values are upheld whether the
law is upheld you know I feel that you
know my security if there's any wrong
I'll be judged by a law that I agree
with and there is you know the result
whatever the judgment is I will accept
because I feel that it's been according
to the Quran and so not to the best of
their been the ability when it came to
the people to get a job and get marriage
was no way so it's strange very strange
you we owe in Afghanistan or where the
foreigners yeah it's just generically
anyone who is foreign if you know Afghan
and you just well they can if you're not
if you don't have grown you're
automatically Arab no matter where you
came from
so you just Arab and but they had it's
kind of there were some issues I think
they they thought I was Chinese because
all they knew was Afghanistan Pakistan
and then anything further with China and
then because I was black so they assumed
no I must be Chinese they didn't they
didn't know beyond some some of them
were kind of they weren't very um versed
in kind of like geography and stuff like
that yeah so yeah the the best
approximation they had was Habashi
which is there was a companion of the
promised awesome use Bilal and he was a
Theo pian and then the term Arabic is
happy she so because they know the
narration of read the stories and things
like that so they and then you is
Blackson and they say oh you must be
happy she happy she so meaning I'm from
the same tribe as this
this companion belong so it was close
enough you know Ethiopia East Africa
Uganda all right I was a vest but some
of them were like China and how can you
do yeah so I wasn't accepted in a
society anyway and I tried to get by how
did you communicate with people with
account oh you didn't just learnt you
just learnt them did you try to learn
the language um it's the best
viewability I mean there were some some
some English speakers there in that
regard and then I'm you know that was it
you know you did your best and then so
basically I think the next significant
thing is must be Massoud Masood Shah
there was this whole thing Taliban has a
commander of northern allies yeah sorry
Northern Lights yeah Taliban had 90% of
the country 10% was held by Massoud
Taliban had the numbers Massoud was
tactical very good strategist and he was
holding the north
something about 10 10 lines or something
that the mountains in the north which is
even the Russians had trouble kind of
breaking that stronghold it was former a
formally Mujahideen and during the
Russian Afghan jihad and then and then
so he was holding that area and then he
gets killed and we hear about it I
thought to myself I said that's it
ten percent Taliban I'm gonna take the
whole country the whole country is gonna
be unified this is great news I think a
day later September 11th happens and
yeah it's it's September 11th happens at
that time we didn't have any the kind of
news because Taliban there was no
television the news that you got was
from like the BBC worldwide like the
radio as a handheld radios and I didn't
know what the World Trade Center was and
things like that you know I didn't I
didn't see any images of it that kind of
thing
only heard it from word of mouth because
I couldn't afford one of those radios a
lot of my money was spent on footwear
because Afghan territory terrain was
just Cove kill your foot way kill it you
spent a lot of money Footwear I didn't
have that much money and what September
11th meant was was a lot of uncertainty
because the thing I didn't know the
scope or the gravity of the whole thing
all I'm hearing his news from one few
people telling you meet on the street
and so forth and and it was either it
was just gonna be the America was gonna
send some creasing missiles few cruise
missiles hit some houses supposedly some
Bin Ladin's or something like that and
then I'm that'll be it or it could be
more than that and for a whole month
there was this whole build up it's gonna
be a war and you're hearing certain
things and you don't know whether to
leave or whether to stay so you kind of
have the people that you're familiar
with and then and then all of a sudden
is just like they're going and finding
their own way out and saving themselves
and then you're kind of just left to
hang and I I did I really didn't know
what to do because I didn't have when I
went to design my camera of Afghanistan
I meant to go and stay and I hadn't made
any plans to you know any exit plan so I
didn't have that much money more money
was depleted because the only money I
had was I was using it the whole the
whole time and so I had to remain and
there's this whole build-up that is
possibly gonna be an attack and you
don't know how long the attacks gonna be
whether it's gonna just be a few cruise
missiles it's gonna be a drawn-out war I
don't know say yeah so he was a whole
uncertainty and then there was this
whole we had stories like in Kabul the
Northern Line some Afghans there were
upset that Massoud was killed and in
September 11th was I think I don't know
they were set up set was an opportunity
so they were killing Arabs in the market
so obviously I'm worried
that you know that I'm considered Arabs
I'm gonna be next I was in Kandahar
living in the kind of the Arabic
institution where they taught Arabic but
they weren't teaching at that time I
tried to enroll but I didn't have enough
people and so you know just I was
staying there but there was nothing much
going on in terms of education so I
remember one time leaving I'm just
stepping out of the compound and then
hearing a bang so I look around to see
where where the bullet had hit because
they go they miss didn't get me but I
was looking around to see what I hit
because I'm thinking what's going on is
it someone shooting me then I hear
another bang and I'm looking around like
frantic now because I don't know which
way to run this is someone shooting at
me and I hear a banging and I look over
and over the across the other side of
the road there was it was just something
to scare the the birds or something like
that nothing there was an Afghan there
who locked because he because he saw he
saw me like like looking like I was
crazy like that but obviously you don't
know what's gonna happen you don't know
you're just gonna step out and someone's
gonna kill you you used to know so I you
know I decided you know I'm gonna have
to not stay in Kandahar City I'm just
gonna have to kind of go out and with a
group of other foreigners we went out to
this outskirts and then we stayed on the
outskirts of Kandahar hiding because it
were kind of afraid that you know the
Afghans will come for us and then we
just hearing news that one city after
another is falling and yes the last news
I heard was that
you know I'm what me the news I heard
was one harmless said that we're gonna
the Taliban I'm gonna pull back tough to
Kandahar and then and they're gonna
fight from Kandahar and then reclaim the
country and then you know they're not
gonna give up and aha and then the next
thing I know is that um okay well
basically I'm on the outskirts and then
um sorry I'm gonna have to go through
that story as well so I'm on the
outskirts of Kandahar and I'm with some
foreigners I don't know there was this
thing we were sleeping like ruff and
then where I was sleeping I think they
were ticks one time and then it was a
snake and then and then like there was
some bombing around the area and it was
a bomb that hit pretty close there was
an Afghan I remember on a bike who was
kind of just riding out in that area and
it's kind of outskirts I'm wondering
whether he's kind of doing recon for
someone and then you know he's he
spotted us like you know the foreigners
and and that's why the bombs are hitting
so close so basically I thought to
myself I'm not gonna sleep here where
the snake and the text or whatever he
said I'm gonna sleep and one of the bomb
craters so I thought I thought we was
safer to sleep one of the bomb craters
so I told my friend I said you know I'm
gonna sleep over there if you see in
cases just so he knows that I'm sleeping
I'm gonna sleep I don't normally sleep
so I slept in the bomb crater and then I
just remember like voices at night
calling I just remember seeing your kind
of silhouette or someone at the edges of
a bomb crater but I didn't wake up and
then then I wake up in the morning and
everyone had gone I was on my own like a
house cause I kinda thought was going on
where has everyone gone and then left in
a rush because things were left the
sleeping bags were left they were just
there just like they just picked up and
went like that so um so basically I pray
my morning my morning prayer and and
then I pick up I scavenge and I find one
of those handheld radios for BBC
Worldwide so I kind of turned it on and
err area was kind of broken so I kind of
shake it about a bit and I hear outside
of the white know and
is that Kandahar had fallen so okay so
there's me there's no number we said
that you know I'm gonna come back to
Kandahar I'm gonna fight from Kandahar
and reclaim Afghanistan and then there's
this news that kinda hard fallen so
basically I was in northern Lions
territory and what were you thinking at
the time run yeah I think he was run
yeah so that's that's what I did so you
know I I just you know I had to get out
way from that place because you know the
sleeping bags all over the place then I
I don't know whether Northern Lights was
it was was around III didn't know what
to do so I just kind of you know I ran
like if any kind of human mind the thing
is there was some dates left so I packed
some dates and then in a bag and then I
kind of I was I was gonna rush just away
from that area but because we were in a
dry riverbed so I was gonna run across
the dry river but I heard voices I heard
voices and then I climbed the decide the
bank I climbed across the bank and all I
saw is a yellow turban and yellow turban
and I climbed a bit more and and I saw
this Afghan approaching I didn't wait to
see whether he had the gonna normal or
whatever I just turned and ran and I ran
down the riverbed and as I was running
the the thought in my head was going
he's gonna shoot me over back he's gonna
shoot me back it's gonna shoot me back I
just kept him running and I'm thinking
he's gonna shoot me back he's gonna
shoot him back he's gonna shoot me back
that's the only thought of it I'm not
breathing so the dry riverbed kind of
went straight and then turned around the
corner and I'm just thinking is gonna
shoot him back and I had to make that
corner and if I'm think he's gonna shoot
me in the back he's gonna shoot me right
you know shooting back and I surprised I
made it around the corner because I
wasn't breathing it didn't help you know
I'm kind of him since or long-distance
running his he should be my thing but
when you're not breathing then doesn't
you know we get far so I made it around
the corner and obviously I'm clamoring
so I just kind of just try to get away
from that place as quickly as possible
and you know I got down the dry riverbed
I got over the top and went on the bank
of the other side and I just hid in the
kind of depression and I remainder and
you know he was he was day it was
daylight Afghanistan his open plane you
can see somewhere for their long time
very far and I'm not really gonna get
away and if they decided to shoot me I'm
sure they could shoot me from a distance
because you know there's not many things
you can hide there's no trees and things
like that so I hid in the depression and
I stayed there the whole day all night
and then the morning came and then I
waken and I look and in a distance
standing on some kind of big rock
there's an Afghan a group of Afghans and
they've got a weapon and they're
shooting at some kind of set of houses
so obviously I'm wrong singing to myself
you know this is getting serious now
because you know before he's a kind of
shooting at a set of houses so but the
thing was I had to get away from that
depression and down in the dry riverbed
and make my way do that here the other
way again I don't know I hid out in some
sort of you know derelict houses just
mud houses like on the side I found
something like T it is eater I mean I
had kind of a can of tuna on my own me
and in there there was like two jam jars
small jam jars one was broken in that
way I knew there was a river in the
distance away from candy hearts of my
priority was water so I made my way
there and it's just you're making my way
across the open plain and then I
remember passing one Afghan I saw him in
a distance and he saw me because the
Afghans I have this thing they don't
walking past they just walk everywhere
so there's no way you can walk in the in
the open kind of in the wilderness and
not come across an Afghan they're always
there so I don't know what's the problem
but that's it so this guy had a
those big machine guns belt machine gun
and he looked to me he was in the
distance I looked at him and I was just
hoping he's just what we won't approach
me and for some reason do you decide to
just walk he looked and maybe he
couldn't see me or something that I from
distance he decided to walk and then I
walked away so I managed to get to the
dry river not the dry river but this is
a actual River it's a red sands I've
seen it on Google Earth there the red
sands very very beautiful red sands and
there's a river that runs along them and
then I climbed up you have to climb up
in order to get to the top I climbed up
and then I came across I'm thinking
okay it's Ramadan but I didn't had any
okay I'm saying okay I think yeah I can
I'm DUP and then I come across this John
Muhammad or something like that and then
um you know I'm trying to talk to him he
tries to talk to me etc and he basically
tells me if I follow the river I'll go
to Pakistan so I thought okay you know
it's good to know and I think there was
someone else I basically I had to try to
get okay I've my memories of the kind of
broken
I remember going across the Red Sands
walking across the red sands and I think
I went in a big circle because I walk
the red sands and I came to kind of you
know the edge of a mountain and there
was a town there and I asked him for
food and then they gave me kind of some
raisins but they said he was Ramadan you
know it should be fasting but you know
I'm a traveler one and I'm in a bad
situation right now and I managed to get
come round and I think I ended up in the
same kind of spot and so basically on
the red sands I found some some kind of
brush and I hid there and then I was
there for three days yeah three days and
I thought I think I got sick because I
was drinking the water and I was I was
confused with others thinking should I
follow the river you know I should I
just I didn't know what to do oh yeah
I'm well a family a family an Afghan
family my guest John Muhammad went
around talking and you know whoever
maybe it was the same person with the
yellow turban after all I don't know but
basically the the family of the Afghans
they found me he sent his son and then
he was searching and he found me in that
area and then he took me to a town to
its small town and on the edge and then
they looked after me they hit me because
they said this John Muhammad was very
interested in me he wanted to read to
Kate me again
and then they told me that there was a
bounty on my head
thirty thousand dollars and and that you
know Jan John Muhammad is very
interested in this money it was looking
for me and he's gonna be around that
town that village looking to see where I
am so they hit me in some kind of
derelict buildings and things that that
gave me some medicine because I I think
the water had affected me
obviously the Emmy food etc and then
they said after Ramadan they have three
days of celebration and then after I was
relieved and then we'll go on a
Smuggler's route and go to Pakistan and
that's what happened we left I left with
the old man didn't get far a 4x4 Buddha
and it was full of Afghans with weapons
so one of them exits and he walks up the
Afghan old man walks up to him and
starts berating him calling mahalo Fein
you know the opposition and telling you
give him good telling off I couldn't
understand what he was saying but he's
really getting give him good telling off
so the Afghan walks up to me and then he
says Muslim animals and man I mean you
must have I said oh yes I am Muslim and
I said to him was a man I said money he
said yes he's Muslim
then he frisked me and takes my passport
and accept all my money and then um then
he indicates like to me I thought he
indicated to go like to out to the open
wilderness so I was happy I think he got
I mean when he was talking to the old
man and I was working the 4x4 I was
looking in the distance I thought to
myself because you know I mean in in
primary school and secondary school at
least early falls saying hurry school I
was a sprinter you know as I was
thinking I could I could run that you
know like you know just take it run but
then you know like then it's this open
area I could run for as long as I like
and then there just shoot you down so
that would be a so he indicated go so I
thought oh excellent so he's telling me
just to go so without my possible
whatever more money I was I was happy to
just leave but he said no no no come
you're going to the 4x4 so they put me
in a 4x4 and then I'm in amongst them
and they're sitting there with their
guns etc
and then they say oh this is the
interrogation I guess that is the best I
could do it I said he's in the bad with
some bin Laden zindabad means long live
so I said zindabad Taliban zindabad was
a mullah Mohammed
so I mean long live Taliban long live my
home and so they I mean they were
McAuliffe in but one of them was former
Taliban because they said oh he they
indicated that he was former Taliban
we'd switch sides
his turncoat like that so in the car
the 4x4 the old man's in the back and
then we drive and then he put me in the
back and I think the old man went in
front and then basically they took me to
spin bulldog which is on the border with
Pakistan spin bulldog the old man left
and then he left me with them and then
they they took me into a house and I see
a picture they'd given me back more
possible I think at this time my money
and then I see a picture and they took
it again and I think it was colors I I
don't know I hadn't seen how those
pictures there's just a picture innocent
to the living room and it's the kind of
like like whose new move Arak and
whatever type pictures of presidents
today you know in Arab countries this
tastes like Gadhafi you see this picture
everywhere oh you did and then so I saw
this picture and then the picture of
Karzai I believe it was colors I like
that so I'm thinking okay so they take
the passport they come back and then in
order to get into the car to where the
woman the blue woman thing or whatever
she which amused the kids because they
they want food so that was that I got
into the car and they took me to the
border and then basically they're
watching the border now sometimes the
Pakistani soldiers they're not there
they don't scrutinize so you can just
drive across but they were there and
were checking every vehicle so I pulled
up to the side and then we're looking
and obviously I'm thinking they're not
gonna get me across they're thinking the
same thing and then I think we I've
really changed cause you know we change
cars and then I was put into another car
and then things got distinctively
threatening so the people that kind of
changed over some of the old ones left
as a state the ones that got me in the
first place but some of the new ones
that he kind of seemed a bit more cold
one of them was in the back and he he
cocked his Kalashnikov near my head and
you know some thinking to myself okay
this is it doesn't look like it's going
my way I thought you know they were
going to help me one was in brothers and
then and then then we kind of drove back
to Kandahar they they said as we were
driving they said you were going to here
out here art is in a border with Iran
and Iran will take you but Pakistan is
not going to take you so they see
morning became night and we're driving
through Kandahar and I'm thinking
they're gonna fulfill their word and
then I start seeing that we're pulling
up two roads where I'm seeing tanks I'm
seeing a lot of armed men and this looks
like kind of the area that compound
their stronghold so they take me there
and then the car just remains there and
they exit and then Afghanistan comes in
into the car and then now he was really
kind of aggressive he seemed to have
kind of he he spoke English with an
accent
maybe spooner I'd say maybe spent some
time in in America or he'd watch a lot
of American miraka movies I don't know
but he said to me something like he said
something like you know we're gonna hand
you over to the British guys the British
guys did not want you were gonna hand
you over to the British guys and then he
just kind of like it seemed angry got
out the car slammed the door and I was
that okay so they're gonna hand me over
to the British I'm thinking and I think
at that time they drove me and they
drove me back to Kandahar City and it
was a familiar sight because there was
there's an arch there's an arch in in
Kandahar and when we used to catch the
rickshaw he used to go through under the
arch when you're going to the market and
you know but now there's there's no
rickshaws and there's not just done that
bustle of the bazaar it's just night and
it's quiet and underneath the arch it is
just to Africa
they have their weapons and then and
then you know I'm sitting in the car and
in the Afghan the original Afghan that
frisked me and then took my passport
he's sitting there and he's nervous
about my hands I don't know why and then
um
he I think we're waiting and I think
we're waiting outside this area is like
Mama's um he used to be one of almost
officers at that time oh so basically
the Afghan I said to him I tried my best
in first tune that if the Americans
enter understand is normally Afghanistan
so I just be careful if the Americans
enter Afghanistan it's normal leave
Afghanistan and then he indicated to to
to go into the building so basically I
enter the building I'm tied up by those
there was Afghans now the building is
crawling with people with weapons I'm
taking into a room and then the first
time I see American soldiers Marines is
then they walk in with the m16s hanging
off their necks and then they they speak
to me in the American accent and I'm
looking at them and I'm thinking you
know the blond-haired blue-eyed you know
I hadn't seen that for a long time and
then basically look at my papers and
they told the Afghans to put me in the
Afghan prison I'm held in the Afghan
prison for two days three nights and
then from there the Afghans take me out
and then I'm taken to a house there was
no furniture in the house etc and that's
when I'm handed over to the Americans
Marines and then they swap cars and I'm
taking on the back of a van and you know
I'm driven to Kandahar Airport and kind
of how I thought at that time was made
into a detention center runway
how'd they get in here um it was just a
short it was just a short short ride
it's no it's not far from Kandahar
Kandahar Airport and part of the road is
tarmacked so once you hit that I knew I
was going to kind of how Apple because
of that because once you hit the tarmac
there in Kandahar having driven so such
a small distance and it must be going to
Kandahar Airport yeah so basically you
know I was I was hooded and riptides and
told to scoot back into into a van and
and I was taken to the Kandahar Airport
which has become the detention center
they threw me on the ground freshmen
Chris my sides then I was taken in in
obviously I'm blindfolded at this point
in time so I'm going by hearing I'm
taken into you know into whatever
facility they have for processing and
then I'm strip naked ain't no search
pictures were taken fully nude pictures
are added because I've not found I'm
later on a detainee in Guantanamo Bay
was shown his pictures of myself he told
me was fully nude there were on the
laptop of a miniature Commission's
lawyer that was defending him so that's
how I know so these pictures were taken
and then I was taken into interrogation
by the Marines and then the Marines were
only concerned with military
intelligence information I didn't have
any to give them and then then the FBI
interrogated me once and then I was
isolated putting what is called the bond
because they thought I was British
special Air Forces Special Air Services
SAS special military forces etc don't
know why they thought that but they
really believed it and then um I stayed
in Kandahar for about three weeks and
then just the general stuff like
background
same things I'm telling you yeah that
kind of thing just just background
schools jobs how you got to Afghanistan
while you're there what did you do when
you're there blow blow cetera yeah yeah
so that's what they wanted to know and
then yeah after three weeks they told me
that I'm going to go before military
commissions or civilian court for
conspiracy conspiracy to do what I never
said
and then I think it was a marine or one
of these soldiers he said that you're
gonna be in a bucket on an
island for rest of your life and get a
life without parole okay whatever so
basically that's the prelude to one of
us so we get processed in Kandahar and
then taken to go on timer with me we've
all seen the pictures of the arrival of
the first mystical Guantanamo wonder if
you can go through that but for us to
describe okay the arriving Guantanamo I
mean whole trip oh okay the trip over
from Kendall no okay um the three weeks
are spending Kandahar's in the world was
termed the bond so I was considered some
special detainee I don't know why and
then after those three weeks I was taken
out and taken for processing and the
only time a I saw another detainee
except for the brief period when I was
taken to the bottom I saw some detainees
there was during the processing so there
was someone before me and then they were
wearing the orange tight suit and and
other paraphernalia
it was my turn time for processing so in
Kandahar they didn't give us a shower
nothing no hygiene etc so to go to
graphic detail what they do is they
shave your head I only had six hairs of
my my chin and I thought well he's not
gonna shave by my beard because there's
nothing there but he gave it one swipe
and then some reason and they they they
dribble with some liquid on your private
parts you're put in that suit and then
moss that restricts thumb movement
handcuffs I gurgles ear muffs and then
then I was taken out and then I was put
in front to lead one line of set of
detainees I remember it was lunchtime
because they gave us the half Afghan
bread the the Red Cross had kind of
sorted out for us because before and we
were only getting two meals a day of
MREs that's meal ready teas as military
kind of Russians and then ate that and
then we're taken out to the to the
runway no no you you hold it oh you just
hold it but yeah you're sitting down and
you move you move you move from the
waist down and eat it but you're wearing
muffs so you can kind of hold some
things but I mean it's a big bread it's
a huge Afghan red so he managed and then
we were taken out to the runway and then
the military have this thing that they
get ready for nothing so they took us
out in the day the Sun would go down and
then we'll put on the planes before they
put us on the planes they would test the
the handcuffs meaning that it wasn't
locked so they would squeeze him so that
because his way of locking him so that
they just they just don't keep on
squeezing your wrist some people got it
worse than another than others they did
it on purpose to cause pain basically
the squeeze mine but
you know praise is due to Allah it
wasn't it wasn't as tough as some other
people and then we'll put on on the
plane and then was strapped in and then
the plane took off the journey I just I
just remember being you know as Muslim
you have to take care of your prayers
and obviously in the detention and being
transferred and so forth
it becomes a warrior so I was worried
about the prayer so that was my concern
at the same time that's what I remember
of the journey
I remember we we stopped off somewhere
hot and then we changed planes briefly
and then the if the flight took off the
soldiers I think we've got one small
peanutbutter sandwich and an apple and
the soldiers ate the rest and the flight
must have been eight hours I seem to
recall 18 hour sorry not eight hours 18
hours and then I remember the the pilots
saying that we're going over
such-and-such American city
I remember the city but I don't remember
the name of it I don't know whether it
was food in just just making a joke or
something like that I remember one of
the soldiers decided to give a hard time
to the British guy myself and then he
started berating the guy next to me I
didn't say anything and then then we
landed in Guantanamo Bay Cuba um I
didn't know who's gonna turn of a bay
and people will be taken out obviously
this is my son
there's no images to these memories this
is by sound and then the soldiers were
silent understand either side of you and
earnest your turn to go down the ramp
and then they're saying things like you
know they're really effing the Marines
are really effing them up and you can
hear the shackles moving faster and they
should do which means that they're
cutting of that the ankles you can hear
people screaming both you know I'm
saying F this and F that f this F that
and
detainee screaming as well you could
just hear all you're doing my hearing
and then obviously I'm kind of getting
tense now because it's my turn next I'm
gonna go down the ramp and I'm gonna get
F top so they put me in the hands of the
Marines and then they lift you up and
check one side
lift your another side your frog March
from one one set of hands to another and
then basically end up on the stress
position so you put us in the compound
and there's this famous Pentagon picture
of the released of us in stress
positions if that is the first picture
I'm one of them
and in our sitting in that stress
position so as the hot Sun there's a
face mask
you know these surgical masks in your
face the sweat is going to surgical
masks you can't breathe
there's the the dog barking there's
someone barking the soldier barking
orders and then a bad translation of
Arabic you know I'm just just sitting
down use the stress position you have to
hold the position your hands have to be
in a certain place so I can't breathe
and you know there was another reason as
well because I hadn't had a toothbrush
for like three weeks in Kandahar
so my breath wasn't smelling that that
good with the face ball so I was trying
to remove it from my nose so you just
kind of move your mouth you know that I
move it from my nose and and I'll try to
breathe in and the soldier would come
back shout at me put it back it cetera
and this was the whole thing anyway for
four hours we got there when it was
probably a mid day and the Sun would go
down and I was still there and I'm just
hearing all the detainees drop like
flies and then they get dragged away and
he can hear the chains and I think I was
the last one and then basically they
came before before they did that they
took my sand off my foot and I don't
know why he took the sand off my foot
and then they they took me out and they
took me out into the processing and then
they you get a shower in front a few
full view of everyone you're naked and
you only got like a few seconds and then
and you go back and they put you in the
jumpsuits and then it is a no search
again and then all I remember is because
with the goggles you could see a little
bit underneath like you could see your
feet or you could see now I just
remember that lighter changed
it was those floodlights that became
very familiar and I remember the
clanking of the gates that were new
sounds to me but they'll become very
familiar
and then I remember like the grass and
then because of the floodlights they're
different color it was there wasn't
green it was just kind of a different
hue and then I was put into my cage and
then they took off the goggles and then
my eyes took a while to readjust I stood
up and looked in the first image I saw
was an Afghan in orange in a cage
similar to mine praying which I later
learned was in the wrong direction
and then I just you know I looked around
and then I was in I was in a cage and my
concern was to pray
I prayed as best as I could during that
whole process but you know I said to her
and let me repeat repeat the prayers
again and I was praying the same
direction as the Afghan so I pray in the
wrong direction as well I know which
direction to pray and then that's it I'm
in camp x-ray before you got on the
plane had you been told you being taken
to Guantanamo Bay oh well no not to go
and tell him away I've been told I'll be
going before military commissions or
civilian courts but I wish it in the
bucket for the rest of my life 100 years
without parole and had had what was life
without parole yeah and I had had you
did you have any idea what to expect
when you before you arrived and walk
down that you know that's fun no not at
all I I didn't I didn't I didn't even
know Quentin available when it existed I
didn't know I mean there's some reggae
or something like that
we've got listen to it or whatever I
mentioned saying that some of the lyrics
party know what went on and they was
existed or was a detention center or
anything like that
so I'm putting an animal cage and my
first impressions were that um this is
quarantine because what I expected was
to go to America and I thought I mean
they starved me in kind of huh and then
you know I'd spoken to Americans before
like you know know before the whole
Afghanistan thing it said run I heard
you know inmates in America are gonna
get swollen yeah big they do waits to
get big they must have food so I thought
wow so the Kandahar my only concern was
food you know because it was starving me
to the point I became very very thin
that I go to America yeah they might be
put me before major commissions or
civilian court but I'll get food I'm
then kind of in quantum Bay Cuba and
then no that didn't transpire it was
we didn't get stolen okay so yeah so
that was it I mean in camp x-ray and
then camp x-ray was I think I I remember
is the first three days not talking
others remember is two weeks to me
they're not talking thing you just sit
in the middle of yourself whether you in
the Sun or not didn't matter
yeah to place to look I look up to the
sky at the ground
the soldiers job was to see whether
you're looking at in any other direction
other than these and then it comes shout
at you that was it but for me that
there's three days to me I remember them
as three days it was kind of like I
could catch up because all of this had
happened and my mind wasn't keeping up
with it
it wasn't keeping up with it so there
was a kind of moment where I could stop
and thought to take it in and he was
during those three days then we were
allowed to talk to the guy next to you
and that kind of thing and then so what
were you thinking in those three days
quarantine I was in quarantine like Adam
was where they they won't allow them
into the country then they need to put
him quarantine check whether they've got
diseases and stuff like that and then
I'm gonna go to America that's what I
thought so I started sitting I mean I
would you had the kind of I so mats they
called him these camping mats and I sat
down I I wouldn't sit on the ice on that
this is after they allow you to kind of
have some slight freedom in your in your
cage sit on the rough floor because you
know the Marines they give you a beating
you know like when they make you sit
cross-legged and then the truck and and
tie you down bolt you down and then if
you move from that position and they
give you kicking and etc so I said I'm
gonna toughen up my legs yeah I'm gonna
sit on a rough floor the concrete floor
and toughen up my legs when the Marines
come and I'll be able to take it you
know they're beating because they're
gonna go to America so I never happen
but it's a good thing you didn't have
everything you know okay because you
know my Arabic is not that good so it's
very rudimentary so I'm there and I'm
trying to understand what they're
talking about know what most of it goes
over my head so they were talking about
a little higher the Islamic month I
thought they were talking about al-qaeda
so I said don't talk about that yeah
no no it's the exact one's gonna fire
because they were talked about and then
no one time though I talked about they
said Ferrari
this is the first time we're hearing for
each key later he had it all the time
and I for some reason I thought that the
word I had this I did at the word for
all was to flee so I thought it was over
my escape oh yeah I kind of shuffle over
the guy next to me I said you know so
what was the plan but no no he said no
no we just uh forestry means that you'll
be released soon so it was a hope that
you really soon through the proper
administration of the US government
they'll release you soon
I thought they were talking about escape
so you know anyway that was that was
that day one and then um yes of just
generally the I guess that the topic of
the day was what was happening in the
camps the latest news and what so-and-so
was told in interrogation and what hopes
people had to be released
Arabs another mix of Afghans yeah yeah
interrogations began one month later so
we're taking in January 11th in February
weekend and then it was HOH I'm gonna
start a whole clean slate
everything you said beforehand is not
gonna be taking consideration they start
your story again okay we have to go
through this whole thing again and then
then it's how the military is
interrogating you or the FBI and then
they saw which one you kind of didn't
like I didn't like the Marines because
the way they treated us and I hated them
so I wasn't in the the military
interrogation I was clammed up the FBI
then they they decided okay they're
gonna you know I'm more conducive
there's more rapport with the civilians
so then they dominated the
interrogations but there was some
military yeah and well what what kind of
questions do they ask you start from the
beginning everything everything yeah
everything the same thing I'm telling
you guys that's it they go through all
of them
did you feel that they were searching
for particular kinds of information
no they just they didn't know who
quickly learned you know coming from the
West I knew that you know you call him
Miranda rights or something like that
here you know you have to be read your
rights and they do not know where I came
from the Afghans just gave him and in
fact the Afghans who kind of who handed
me over lied
they said I was found loitering after
curfew in Kandahar City that's not
that's not reality they found me on the
outskirts of Kandahar in the morning
they after curfew they lied they lied to
them so the u.s. you know administration
did not know who they have they didn't
know our names they didn't know anything
about this I mean I mean they had my
passport and things that I said I knew
that etc but they didn't know anything
so you starting from that how can you
build up a case against someone if you
don't know where they've come from who
they are what they were doing you just
you just hand it over for money and the
Afghans can say or the Pakistanis can
say whatever they like about them so I
really learned so I thought to myself
from the beginning you know this is
today they're gonna they're gonna frame
me they're gonna make up something and
then I'm gonna be in life in prison for
the rest of my life because they don't
know they haven't read me my rights and
they don't know where I've been what
I've been doing etcetera well how can
they know so I really believed they were
gonna frame me and I work towards I said
I'm gonna be there for the rest of my
life
and you know I'm just gonna have to make
do with with what I can do and just live
my life and then I really believe that
up until the end I really believed him
so how did you what kinds of things did
you just did you decide to do to make do
okay you had two types of detainees in
my tumbly
I know it's cliched you had the ones
that hope for release and you had the
ones that kind of didn't hope release
and go on with their life so yeah I mean
I just tried to read what I what I could
I had the Koran I tried to improve
myself in that way you know just you do
your best this we were mainly reading or
in trying to improve yourself we were
with whatever books in that way there's
always the whole survival aspect and
then you know you try to as
Muslim you try to better yourself in
terms of your worship and things like
that so that that's what I tried to do
but I didn't have any hope that will be
released
I was I was determined they were gonna
frame me I'm gonna make up lies about me
this and that in the other etc and then
I was gonna go it's gonna remain there
forever when was the first time that you
had some kind of interaction or message
or an attempt with intended engagement
with a lawyer
oh that's a long time that's skipping
like like four anyway so camp x-ray um
yeah so I'm in camp x-ray and then I
think it was March 2002 day they move us
to Camp Delta and unfortunately the
Arabs they they believed that oh this is
it
they'd made a mistake and now we're
gonna take it home you know one of the
detainees there he'd been talking to
interrogators and the interrogator that
told him you know there's a new
permanent prison etc account Delta
that's where you're going so I believe
that more likely than the other didn't
the hopes of the Arabs I tried to tell
him they didn't want to hear it and then
we got transferred it's the same the
Marines they came and you know you get
the battering and kicked and punched and
as you've been taken to on the bus to UM
Camp Delta and there I was I see Camp
Delta Delta charlie block
I was Charlie one well it's the transfer
when you're being transferred you're
being transferred to Vereen some reason
actually do with you in detail is
day-to-day basis at that time it was the
kind of the military some reserve some
national girl God some more full-time
military they do it with you on a
day-to-day basis but the Marines were
there I think for security so they'll
deal with the transfer and in Oviedo
Cuba kicking and punching et cetera then
there's the earth team when they say
that your contravening some role or
other they will come in when right gear
and endo
don't knock you down and beat you up
sometimes and then take you out into the
isolation and that kind of thing
yeah did that happen to you oh no I was
I wasn't I wasn't
yeah anyone would know that were you in
Kandahar the IC RC came in and I said to
them they asked whether I wanted to send
a message to my family I said yeah I
wrote a message they asked whether the
concert wants to be informed obviously
at that time I thought the Afghans had
told her already because that's what the
Afghan said but I said yeah you know
informed the consulate British Consulate
and then in camp x-ray I think after a
month
supposedly they claim to be consular
officials they came under no you know
they talked to me so it was oh it was
obviously you know some people knew I
was there I don't know I think during
camp x-ray I got a message from my
mother's Red Cross I think or maybe the
the u.s. a mailing system rather then I
wrote a message but yeah yeah I was
aware that people you know people knew
that was there what was Camp Delta like
okay um I was detained in camp x-ray
camp Delta camp echo and the trend is
that I preferred camp x-ray and he just
got worse as you went by the thing about
camp x-ray was more informal so the
soldiers I mean they could be mean to
you
I remember one soldier called Philips he
he took a dislike to me and then um he
told me one time that this is in camp
x-ray there me and him are gonna go
around and round one day or something
like that yeah
it was I think it was from the south or
something like that and then one time he
took the keys and he was rushing to to
my door because he was gonna open it and
have a fight with me or something like
that cetera so there was no informal but
you get some other guards who
like who what kind of nicer because I
didn't really know what to do in that
situation but did you go over time and
you go over camps they became more cold
more systematic in their ways the the
cells in camp x-ray the the mesh that
they were using was the same that you
find in parks the green kind of fencing
in camp Delta that there was more metal
and less to see through and in camp echo
even got worse and things like that so
things just became more isolated more
alienating over over the camps camp echo
to me was as long as the only problem
was the soldiers bothering you if they
harassed you then you know you have a
problem other than that I just kind of
you know it would be sunny you'd feel
the wind because you're near the ocean
you'd hear the chime of the razor wire I
just get on with my reading and you know
there may be some note-taking and things
like that and I like the kind of hearing
the Arab brothers in the background just
speak I didn't understand what they were
saying but that kind of just hearing him
in the background you know it's just it
was nice I wouldn't I would I'll keep
myself to myself and keep quiet but I
like to add your connection is I don't
know it's just like a feeling that maybe
have tentacles that reach out and you
know you can the whole block you can
feel the energy of the block and then
you can hear those as well it was nice
apart from that been taken into
interrogation but the interrogations
thought you know interrogation was a
bonus as they put it you know you get to
leave that shithole I prefer the excuse
me shithole or rather than the
interrogation itself because I had
freedom to walk around in myself rather
than being bolted to the ground and you
tell me the interrogation was better
mine I'd say it was kind of it was okay
and then um but then they took me to
come echo he kept interrogating you
okay now the thing was I got the
impression that there's a disjuncture
between what's happening when tunnel
away and what Washington is being told
because what they were concerned about
the interrogators they weren't concerned
about your story anymore you told your
story they have it on record finished
they weren't concerned about the story
anymore what they're concerned about is
you talking so if you talk about cricket
or football whatever that was the only
concern that you talked and - my feeling
was they can say that this guy is
talking so they can send a report to
Washington and say oh so many people
were talking if you didn't talk they got
nasty
they got nasty and they started you know
if you said I have the right to remain
silent I've told you my story you guys a
bunch of jokers I have nothing more to
say I want my lawyer they get nasty they
start really messing you up and there
was a period of time when power was
given to the interrogators before like
your comfort items they call him medical
treatment letters home was given to
interrogators and if you wanted to write
a letter home you had to go to the
interrogator because they said if you
even have to talk to them you can't just
clam up and not say you don't wanna talk
to you have to talk didn't matter what
you're talking about you had to talk and
then medical treatment you had to go
through the interrogators and that's
where it got really harsh they were
already really handling people really
severely did they try to talk to you
about football thankfully yeah yeah but
the thing was that every time I opened
my mouth to say something no use it
against you so for instance they asked
me about like what was your last job so
I said like I said macros I was a
wholesalers because I knew like I've
watched enough American movies and
things like that yeah I said I was a
general assistant i stacked shelves yeah
I've watched enough movies to use the
terminology so the allegation they don't
because thinking back I think to myself
did I ever ask me interrogation are you
acquired at it I don't remember them
asking me it was always by implication
that they'll take what you said and then
it indicates that you were acquired but
they never asked you directly so I said
to myself I said to them you know I was
a general assistant i stacked shelves
later I learned because in on the blocks
there was a green book where they keep
daily log of what
happened whether there was a right who
got food water etc in that is the
allegations the soldier comes and tells
me the allegation is I'm assistant
general I'm not lying I'm assistant
general I was assistant general in
Afghanistan I was come from but it came
from the interrogation so because I said
I was a general system I stash shelves
they twisted it around and said his
assistant general then later another
time they all said what did you do at
home I said do you know I I got into
some baking I like bread so I decided to
do my own bread in my mom's kitchen it
was over it was a period of time when I
decided to go do baking the allegation
is explosive expert like Steven Seagal
I'm not lying this is what the soldier
comes and tells me on the block
explosives expert like Steven Seagal
because one of them like my martial arts
movies one of them Steven Seagal is like
a cook he was demoted and he's on a ship
and then and then I think he blows up
the microwave or something like that
because you know I don't know whether
the ships attacked something easy or
anyone who can save it whatever Stevens
to go like that so this is this is the
allegation and then and another time
this is in camp echo just out of the
blue the soldier says you know like he's
been watching CSI I don't know about CSI
whatever just crime scene whatever
movies investigation or something and
and they said that you know the murder
if the plot goes in a wall and you wash
it off you know they can shine a light
on it and it will show up so you know
gonna watch out because all this
massacres you did in Afghanistan I'm
gonna be winning you're gonna get your
day where did it come from these
massacres in Afghanistan why where did
it come from the the interrogators it's
their job wasn't to you know work out
with you and terrorists or no it was to
prove that you were terrorist whether
you were terrorists or not that was it
so whatever you said they'll twist it
and it only proved to me that they're
gonna they're gonna unframed me but what
I didn't understand was why didn't they
just lie they did it seemed like they
were covering their own
backsides you know they didn't wanna
live at the same time they wanted you to
implicate yourself from your words so
they would do silly things like for
instance I remember one time I said
because I think the conversation came
across on because they always thought
the
the blocks when you camped out it was a
shithole and one interrogate kept on
referring to it as the shithole all the
time you know and then like you know he
thought he was really bad although he
didn't understand the interrogation was
worse than the shithole so he I came
around to the conversation I said too
much I said to him you know look I think
one time I said to him this is not the
worst and I've had in life you know like
that the worst was when I was like a
teenager you know you know this is you
know this is not the worst time in my
life you know and I still believe that
you know because at the end at the end
of my teenage years attempted suicide
wearing one ton of a bay and I was in
the case you know it was like you know
it was a hard time this is a difficult
time but you persevere so you know my
teenage years were worse than Guantanamo
and interrogators kind of obviously
shocked but he said why I said I just
said all because maybe maybe the
testosterone was something or that you
know how it is I don't want to go into
too much detail and but I really believe
they used that against me they really
use that against me they took me to camp
echo and then but this is OK cam Delta
if I just can should I come on to the
camp echo because yeah if we can take a
okay I'd stop talking to in there Tara
Gators how long have you been in Montana
at this point oh yeah anniversary I
remember having my year I spent my year
anniversary in I was in isolation I was
put in the accordion Ferrari the MSU
maximum-security units for punishment
the the new they weren't supposed to
touch the Koran and then like they took
someone to recreation and senior soldier
came and started frisking through the
Koran with the towel I was in the same
block and the news got to me that he was
doing that so I started shouting you in
English then the riot happened it just
detained he started kicking and throwing
stuff and you know making a big fuss
about it I was calling him Nazis and
then basically then
we were taken to for punishment in the
msu maximum security unit um so I was I
was taken there and basically I spent my
anniversary in isolation so which was
kind of okay but basically March 2003
yeah March 2003 one interrogator he said
his name was Highlander and he said he
was Scottish he's American but Scottish
origin and he basically said that you're
going up to him for the Military
Commissions I stopped talking to
interrogators I wasn't saying anything
to them clammed up I was gonna say
anything at all he asked me whether I
had any questions I didn't and they took
me back to the blocks then I think maybe
a few days later I'm taken out of the
block and I'm taking on a medical
vehicle and a strange thing is I'm taken
out of Guantanamo and I'm driven to a
town in Guantanamo where I'm driven
there and I'm taken to a hospital and
I'm seeing proper streets and suffered
that and then but there was a cabin
naked like near the hospital and then
they give me a CT scan so then I'm taken
back to Guantanamo taken back to the
same block and in a few days after that
they come for me and then they the same
kind of vehicle so I thought well maybe
it's the because um in camp x-ray that
the TB had registered positive but the
reason why is because we we have a
immunization injection here called BCG
you haven't when your teenager and any
test would would register positive but
you it doesn't mean that you have it you
have you been immunized against this so
it registers so I thought maybe that was
it I was always worried about the TB
maybe it's the latent and he's become
active now in my even my lungs or
something either so they take me into
the into the vehicle and I'm thinking
okay this is a medical trip and then
they take me to come back home and come
back I was very very strange very
strange situation and when they took me
is strange well I think it was the same
night Iraq was bombed the beginning in
the Iraq war I don't understand why
that's what they did so they take me and
a camp echo it's it's a normal cell but
one in an extended building without
windows and then there's a section for
the detainee separated and there's a
section for the soldiers and then they
stay there 24/7 watching you and
literally before they were stunned
overdoes sitting near the cage and just
watch you and the green book they would
write everything you did have minute by
minute I noticed because the soldiers
later who they transferred they changed
soldiers and so forth the soldiers read
those books and they told me that you
know everything from detainee stands up
detainee sits down detainees sleeps
titania gets up detainee picks up pen or
things and they're just scrutinizing and
then they're but within two weeks of
getting there they gave me an
immunization shot and then within two
weeks of that there's a growth of my
right testicle and I started getting
worried and they just you know you know
this is very strange and because I got
an inkling from the interrogations that
they will use what you said against
against you I think that when I said oh
yeah because there's testosterone they
decided okay this is gonna crack this
guy isn't gonna crack this guy so they
use medical tree leaves this they gave
me injections people don't really
believe about new information is coming
out every every so often and then they
gave me that injections and then after a
month during that period of time they
were taking my blood pressure my heart
rate etc those tests every day every day
and sometimes twice a day and I thought
to myself what's going on in camp Delta
I'd spent I'd made an effort and I
really really tried to stay away from
medical treatment because I knew that
you know once they get you there then
they have leverage over you if you need
to medical trimming but now I'm just
getting a medical attention every day
and it's unwanted so I'm worried that
you know there's this biting my milk or
something like that or my food because
now they have control of my environment
on the Block it's this mess so they
can't really control
your environment but here you know I'm
just a single detaining a single single
cage and then after a month of soggy and
panic attacks I'm sorry I just feel that
someone is attacking me and you know I'd
wake up scream fight something off you
know I just and it's it it was a
disjuncture like friends I'm thinking to
myself what am i what am i doing this
thoughts in my head that are not my own
there's emotions that I'm feeling that
not on my own I can just feel a
separation and everything my bodily
movements you know I'm defending myself
from from from an assailant that I can't
see I'm thinking to myself what am i
doing but at the same time physically
I'm defending myself against assailant
so there's the whole disjuncture with my
whole being was a mentor with a physical
with emotional there's me and then
there's there's other than me and it's
all all one and you know this is
happening and basically I crack and then
I wasn't speaking Tintin to
interrogators they got the earth gear
because the doctor the strain thing with
the doctor was she came every day and
then she kind of got disillusioned and
then one of the soldiers because I tried
to play it down but nothing was
happening with me because I thought wow
they're gonna get they're gonna finish
me off it looks like they're not gonna
frame me they're just gonna give me
another injection send me crazy and and
say oh he went crazy he couldn't
technically couldn't handle it cracked
what can you do and that was that was
there what I'm gonna do because they had
no way out from finished situation they
weren't gonna say sorry so I was keeping
it tone tone down with the doctor and
then but one of the soldiers when I
blabbed and then the doctor run comes
running back I'm saying oh you have
immunization shots I said this is like a
month later you don't you I mean I was a
shot you got like every six months or so
and then I saw I was thinking it's
strange that she came she spoke to me
she didn't say anything she went but
when the when the soldier told her about
the panic attacks then she comes running
back something and this is it they're
gonna finish me off or something like
that so she comes with immunization
shots not the next day like she said she
comes the same night she tells me that
oh there's such-and-such a per tried to
say have tired to be or whatever you
know I say no then a male doctor comes
the next day he tells me another thing
it's not hepatitis A hepatitis
whatever is something else something why
can't they keep the story straight you
know you know because of these
immunization shots so I refused and
they're gonna earth me and then they see
I cracked according the interrogators
that was my only way out and that's the
only time I ever really liked the
cracked as it were that's why that's
what they did to me so I said you know
like oh no I want to go home and that's
the only time I asked him that I want to
go home because before that I asked him
I would say to them you know put me for
trial give him our day in court if you
say I'm dissing any other
give me my day in court that's the only
time I cracked and then basically
according the interrogators the
interrogator rearranged the immunization
shots and then and I'm kind of okay
after the shots I'm I'm kind of fine I
mean there were some issues residue but
I was kind of okay and then I was there
because one interrogator said he
promised me a year ago that I would be
out in Guantanamo this is promise come
true I don't remember the promise I
didn't care for the promise anyway
because you know they'll lie to you
anyway and and he said that I was there
for the military commissions I was going
to be the first one to go out for
military commissions and and you know I
don't know they just threatened me the
military commissions for I mean I was in
camp back over for about two years
solitary so that the threat of military
commissions was there for the whole time
at the end of the at the end of it they
just dropped the thing they dropped the
thing and I said so I spent two years in
solitary and then in
as hell
you move on to something else
yeah so in 2004 I think summer can
remove the month and surprise surprise I
get a lawyer
you told you I think I've got a lawyer
from I think sorry I got a letter from
Geetha I think I got a little first or
something I can remember the process but
I didn't believe it because you you know
no was pretending you hear stories of
them pretending to be whatever so I mean
those stories that they pretended to be
the icrc stories pretending to be you
know the stories uh some military you
know soldiers will pretend interrogation
to pretend to be the FBI which they Fei
didn't like at all because in the major
would do bad things and then the FBI
said that they you know don't end up
holding the bag because they don't want
happy there was there was there was
friction between the FBI and the other
and the other interrogator as well so
you didn't believe anything they said so
I didn't believe it and you know until I
saw a Gita and then she came and she was
my lawyer she came to visit me in camp
echo yeah I was like I wasn't I wasn't
gonna get excited because I thought to
myself you know is it real or not like
that you know so just you know like you
just play it cool
so yeah but it was a kind of worked out
kind of worked out so it opened the door
for me I thought to myself you know at
that time there was a CSR Teese
combatant status review tribunals which
I was preparing for and also is the the
habeas corpus and I think that's the
first time I ever heard habeas corpus
and Gaeta explained it to me and that
what was happening there I mean I could
write letters confidential
attorney-client letters and things like
that so I thought that was a real
opening but I thought to myself it's not
gonna last long it's it's it's but it
was it was progress where you know for
years you just don't see any change
members lawyers who talk about their
feeling that they were kind of a window
on the world yeah
to me yeah Geeta was was an opening and
I could write my you know I could I
could write what's happened to me and
send it as a turning Klein it was like I
could have my story out before they
close that door cuz I read he believes
they were close that door and you know I
wrote a big document of abuse just
detailing what happened to me you know I
sent it to her because I felt you know
the me let me let me do this now because
they're just gonna change the rules and
she's not gonna be allowed and although
he's gonna be allowed to Guantanamo so
this is my opportunity and you know it
did it did it didn't make a difference
to know that you know everyone you meet
other than other day another detainee is
not against you made a lot of difference
and it you know some of the news you got
because in Guantanamo especially in camp
echo I felt that with we've forgotten no
one cares about us and that's the
impression they wanted to you to have
and you know it's a good day
you know Geeta would bring some some
news anyway I mean she wasn't allowed to
bring too much I don't think etc but you
got some Inklings and some suggestion
that you know he won't forgotten and
then what happened with these what
happened after these meetings with Akita
um all the Geeta left and a night to
prepare for the CSRT and then we had to
see SRT and what did they tell you the
CSR she was going to be oh oh they said
you're you're an enemy combatant and you
have to prove you not yes that's it and
then you have a someone to represent you
but they're not really on your side so
if you tell him anything then he's gonna
be could be used against you because I
have to reveal that so I was like okay
like yeah whatever so I mean I prepared
I was getting legal briefs from Geeta
she left some so I decided to use that
as the template and I was walking myself
memorizing because I knew they're gonna
take my papers away from me they're
gonna do something like that so I'd walk
myself I tried to memorize it so if they
did I could say I could say
wrote so it gave me something to do so I
was defending myself now legally I was
mounting my own case and strategizing
and then yeah so from there they took me
back to population camp Delta and then
we weren't wearing the orange we were
wearing a beige you're I was among stuff
the few detainees are going up for
military commissions and then what if we
stick for a few moments on testimony
first yes okay because all over the web
Malcolm X oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
it was it was both an admonition to
whoever was gonna give me the CSRT
because I didn't know I knew there was a
tribunal or something so you know the
thing is you have to present Islam to
people and for two reasons one maybe
they would ever see the light and then
they become Muslim another because Allah
won't punish anyone until they've
received the message so I thought if
this guy's gonna do me over which I
expect let me let me kind of present
Islam to him and then you know you would
do me over now but in the later on you
he would get done over by Allah so there
was that one and then there was
obviously the the stuff about
international law and the arguments that
my lawyers are putting forward in a
habeas corpus which I which I
incorporated in into there and yeah what
was the response to a customer oh well
sorry
well whatever rank he was he didn't want
to hear about international NGO and that
kind of threw me because I thought they
were going to take my papers but they
didn't so all I could do was just keep
on going with with my narrative which I
had before me and he kept on mentioning
international law so he said if you
mentioned international again you're
gonna get thrown out so I could I go
thrown out that was done yeah did you
have conversations with some of the
other detainees about she watches the
CSIT CSRT happened when I was in camp I
couldn't you couldn't even see another
detainee yeah then I think
when we were take him back to the
population camp Delta that's the first
time I see Mozambique but he'd been my
companion in camp echo the whole time
but I hadn't seen him only hear and hear
of him and sometimes we swapped letters
if the soldier was being nice he was
also clatters but I've never seen and
then yeah so we had conversations in
camp Delta and we must approach the
subject yeah we did yeah because he was
telling me he didn't get involved but I
told him I did and he went through all
of them and that's my guess finding out
okay the whole thing yeah up to up to
the flight know what happened after the
civility who told you okay I'm in Camp
Delta I'm wearing beige now because
Military Commissions your you wear
different color and for two years now
I've been threatened with the military
commissions I'm going to be going for
two commissions there were suggestion of
the death penalty and so forth the first
one person that told me that I might be
going home was funnily enough another
detainee Ali bahu bahu Luther Yemeni
detainee is he got life in the military
commissions say supposedly al-qaeda's
made media guy but the thing was it was
because we got measured up they took us
out of ourselves and they strangely
enough they didn't take us out with our
shackles just took you out in front of
the cell and they measure you up with a
tape measure I mean Mozambique so I
thought oh this is for a suit because I
heard one of the other detainees was
wearing a suit to his military
commissions or something other so II
know that you have to wear a suit so I
guess is for the suit and then but Adi
bajo he'd seen the other British
detainees how does the process and he
said no you're going home so I said yeah
going home then I think some time goes
by economy or how much time and then we
just taken out were taken out of there
as they normally do because sometimes
they just moved you for the sake of
moving you and they took my stuff and
then me and Mose am and we're taking us
I thought this is being taken to another
another block or something like that
cetera but Andy baha'u'llah and the
others were saying goodbye remember us
write to us that kind of thing etc and
I'm thinking you guys are joking we're
not going home yeah okay I'm taking back
to camp echo and one of the blocks I've
been taken to before and then then a
soldier comes and he reads out a
statement saying that they're going home
any allegations against you whether or
any any allegations have been dropped
and then he walks off I didn't believe
him because they do this all the time
and I wasn't going to believe it then
and then they then I think I'm waiting
for a lawyer's visit I can't remember
some reason I'm taking out my my cage
and I'm bolted down like normally a for
lawyers visit or something like that in
the same in a similar block and then
Clive Stafford Smith he he does it he
was doing this thing that you know he
would pretend that he didn't know which
block to go to he's come to visit client
and then he'll go into the wrong room so
he ends up in my room and he kind of
walks in and then he's very tall and he
looks at me and then he kind of doesn't
register who I am and then he sits down
and tries to talk to me so I talk to him
back in English and he realized oh you
have a seat so I said yeah and he said
oh the news is true yeah you're going
home that's awful okay all right oh now
this is getting interesting
yeah because it's coming from someone
other than you know the administration
and this was the first time you met
close yeah this is the first time you
know he's kind of pretending he went
into the wrong room and then so he said
oh I gotta go and he talked out okay so
okay so I thought okay yeah
that's great I think Geeta told me I
can't move or the Geeta maybe I was
waiting for heater but she said maybe
she said I can't remember and then
that's it so you're thinking to yourself
you're going home but I'm thinking to
myself you know is it true or not
you know you don't yeah our thing was
the hotel you're going home you couldn't
home you go home which is a bad sign
because he means they're gonna screw you
over and then until I see it until I
have my foot on UK UK jurisdiction and
no I'm not gonna believe it and then
they came and then the FBI took
fingerprints and you know and then the
change to the car clothes
I wanted to I have always had this image
that you know you daydream if I come off
the plane
I'm gonna come off an orange and my hair
is gonna be this hair disheveled and my
eyes are gonna be wild I'm just gonna
look like a really really messed up here
that's still gonna be iconic but they
didn't they wouldn't let me keep the
orange suit so out to weather the kind
of jeans types of stuff that they sent
us and then were taken out from there
onto a bus this time it's not the
Marines I think yeah it had seats just
strange snow and then we were bolted and
then yeah and then there were taken out
with one tonne of the bay we crossed the
river I think you know we're taken to
the runway and there was a plane yeah
there was a plane and the strange thing
was a British Metropolitan Police I
think they came on board the bus
it was a familiar sight for very strange
incontinent of the way you know the
whole mix is the Guantanamo Bay
detainees there's the soldiers and
there's British motor of multiple
bulletins police they're sweet they had
been really yeah yeah because I was told
about it the constant fish who came with
the news hoping that I'd break down and
cry again in front of him I guess
because he said it was some kind of
stifled glee and he asked me what do I
think about it he basically he put it to
me as you know some people are going to
be released UK nationals but it's not
you I don't know what do you think about
that obviously I was happy because it
was it was good news that some some
movement was happening
although it wasn't me it kind of cracked
the the Guantanamo Bay as if the place
that you caught you can't leave
especially well for the UK nationals
so it was good news for me but yeah I
knew that left and I think Tariq I knew
he'd left as well do you know he was
doing
it was still yeah and with you on the
bus was more than with you who was on
the bus
it was Mozambique Martine Bunga Jamal
Harris Jamal Burma and what were you
saying to each other at the time you're
cracking jokes Rosenberg and Martin
started talking in the gym Jamaican
dialect because they had the translator
there who is listening for first of all
we switched into Arabic to talk to each
other and then like then we clocked on
one of them was as a translator who's
picked up and picked up Arabic so Martin
and Mozambique switched into kind of a
Jamaican English dialect and then he
tried to speak to me but I don't
understand this like I didn't I couldn't
get into a conversation and he was
cracking cracking jokes like you know
it's just it was weird but at the same
time you reserved because you know you
know that you got the police there
Metropolitan Police and you don't know
what's gonna happen are they gonna
arrest you and when you know you land
whatever what are they doing that you
know so you're kind of reserved in a way
you know anxious I want to be strapped
this session by talking about the
homecoming getting off off the plane to
what coming home was it coming home
okay well we're still on the plane an
employee plane lands in England UK and
then then you know I'd had hadn't been
arrested before in the UK or anywhere
yeah you can't I mean unless you called
one time a and and that being arrested
but hadn't been arrested so basically
I'm arrested as the plane lands and I'm
told whatever I could I could hardly
hear what the woman was saying over the
the engine the wrong engine and so forth
one rested for some terrorism charge
whatever cetera he was obviously my
worst fear because I didn't want to come
back here and and face prison here as
well and then we're taking her to
Paddington Green police station
the question was stupid the best
questioning they had was they said
such-and-such newspaper said you did
such and such a move over in
such-and-such and what is that true mr.
Bussie hard to answer no comment that's
what my lawyer said and then that was it
so three newspapers and that was it so
he's only it was it was kind of just
routine and then we'll put him in the
back of a police van and then were taken
out and then I can remember I think we
ended up in another car with my lawyer
and then it was you it was a new
homecoming because I looked out to the
window and it was night and I could see
those amber lights and then the black
taxis that I'm used to and the concrete
and the familiar familiar image that I
hadn't seen for years but it was
familiar and he was raining and I was
depressed that's really depressed yeah I
kind of daydream sometimes in guantnamo
that they were just dump me my orange
suit and Afghanistan somewhere out in
wilderness and I'll just run
it was it was a hope you know not really
sticking but that's what I hoped and
they brought me back in to your family
yeah I mean I thought I saw my family
this is good my family but you know
twice I've left this place and I thought
I made sure that I wouldn't come back
you know and unfortunately I'm still
back here and so what did you do in do
the weeks the months not to come back
well the thing was you know you can't I
had I had to hit the ground running
because I didn't want to stop I didn't
want to reflect on what was happening I
mean in Guantanamo Bay you in survival
mode you're you know going day by day
surviving and looking for any which way
to survive and better your chances of
doing so coming here is like all of that
could threaten taking you over you know
you could get engulfed in the whole what
what's happened to you I mean in
Guantanamo and you didn't have time to
process it you were in it and you had to
just deal with it there and then but you
know to look back was it was something
that is not it wouldn't have been good
for me
so I knew right from the past that you
know if you have to deal with something
emotionally you have to deal with it you
have to deal with it but you can choose
when so I packaged it and I just you
know I decided to get on with my life I
went to college I enrolled in college
again I did a access course access to
University and then I was successful in
the access course and I got into
University there was some funding issues
along the way but you know they were
sorted out
and you know I went to university for
three years that's college was one year
university was three years but where did
you go to university
it's a London University I want to say
which one specifically you know I
basically I took up from where I left
off before you know I became Muslim and
then you know went to my kind of trip
and yeah so during University I I got
married and at the end of the university
you know I became a father what kind of
Greek it was a Bachelors of Science in
Social Policy it kind of it was the
first subject
it was right it was a change for me
because I think it's kind of like
college was the first time that I she
wrote an essay because most of my
subjects before that were kind of
electronics physics science based and
this was a switch this was switch to
writing which was strange were I guess
he was just that whole trend I went back
into that welfare thing again that
social policy because when I came out of
Guantanamo I had this thing that I
wanted to understand how governments
affect people their people the welfare
was one of them in social policy
something I came across it's relatively
new subjects I think in America you call
it public policy but I'm the overlap but
they're not the same thing in totality
which worth oh well islamically you
don't you don't cut it it's not by
chance so you arranged to meet so my
aunt said she knows a you know someone
who's looking to get married and then we
met in the mosque with the Imam there
and then the Imam said talk for two
weeks and then come back so we talked
for two weeks over the phone came back
and he said is there any issue is
anything going everything going okay
okay talk for another two weeks we
talked for another two weeks and he come
back to us your decision and then yeah
we decided to get married yeah yeah we
decided to get married and I have a
young father
as a baby boy how old he's gonna be too
soon one month away from two year
terrible two of her terrible twos get
note to you in there too
and he's getting a bit no team in most
times book he says you went for
counselor counseling psyche is a
psychological counselor no not really I
went to Helen BAM before Oh number of
things but no no extensive counsel you
know know as long time since I read his
book but I don't remember that part but
yeah I'm know yeah so I was that's a
finish University and then you know I
was looking for work and then I came to
gauge business how come - how did you
find them okay so what happens is until
up to February this is 2009 2010
he's 2009 things were going rosy and in
the credit crunch happened and then
people losing jobs left right and center
I thought to myself you know I'm set I'm
gonna believe University and then I'm
gonna get a good job and yeah I get on
with my life etcetera that didn't happen
you know it's it's you know I had this
thing about I guess I wanted to prove
prove to myself that I'm more than
Guantanamo
you know Guantanamo is just a part of my
life is not the totality of who I am and
what I am about so you know yeah I
haven't been able to get away from
Guantanamo and you know no matter where
I go it kind of follows me and you know
trying to find a job except with this
big hole trying to explain if you
explained they don't want to know and if
you tried to kind of massage it they it
doesn't work so to find a job wasn't so
basically with them caged prisoners you
know I decided to approach them you know
just to see whether I could you know we
might agree and so forth you know they
utilized an opportunity to come on board
and do some good work before then I'd
stayed away steered away from anything
to do with one ton of modes in the news
etc I just shot myself off but it come
it come to about five years and I
decided after five years I'm gonna have
to open that package and you know this
is this is one good way of doing so
after five years I joined Kate prisoners
and open that package had you heard
about them before yeah when I when I
came out and I heard about them when I
come across them a few times
they tried to keep in touch but
obviously I was doing something else I
was busy with my studies and etc or
trying to work and so I didn't I didn't
really keep close touch but yeah they
kept in touch and obviously through the
other detainees as well you know there
was there was some contact and some
mention of them do you remember one of
the early projects that you might have
worked on when you first joined um yahoo
is a Horn of Africa report awesome
Kureishi had started it and I was
supposed to finish it
so it was interesting how you know in a
different kind of context you saw some
other things and I could relate my
experience was giving me kind of an
insight in a way I could I could see you
know you know just read about reading
about it on a theoretical level you know
I understand what is someone gives their
testimony and say they went through this
and etc you know I have some deeper
understanding and a normal person would
if they're just reading it on face value
and what were some of the findings of
the whole of Africa um it's always the
same rendition torture abuse know due
process and stuff is that our work is
always the same it's not so much just
maybe the distinction that the same kind
of dynamic as you've got Afghanistan
you've got Pakistan and you've got other
areas like Guantanamo Bay I'm kind of
replicated in the Horn of Africa so it's
a different countries but they play the
same role and I was a finding that was
awesome so I think I just had to
complete the report that was the first
piece of research urgent yeah we were
hired as a researcher I was hired as a
researcher yeah and then yeah so an only
changed the caseworker and volunteer
coordinator which is whatever what was
involved in that change it's not it's
just kind of just isn't changing title
is more or less the same um just instead
of dealing with writing a report I
started just dealing with individual
cases themselves a case worker and then
because the cage business was expanding
so we're getting interns we're doing the
report writing so it doesn't make sense
that I did a report writing as also I
might as well do some casework and then
awesome qureishi he kind of got promoted
to executive director so he has to deal
with the bureaucracy and he was a
caseworker before so someone had to feel
that I kind of avoid can you give you a
couple examples of cases note that from
that period your earliest cases
well from that period oh there's been a
lot of cases oh my god be real with you
Oh perhaps a case that for you is
particularly striking I'm sure many of
them love it
I've dealt with so many cases just to
pick out one it's they kind of I think
you see the same thing there's that it's
not really any kind of distinction
between the cases unfortunately it's the
same it's just torture so same thing you
see torture renditions no due process
you know just detained without trial
same stupid questions
you know profiling etc that you know the
names change torture my rendition how
did that due process attention abuse and
how are you helping people do what do
you do actually refer people to place a
sword now we try to kind of bring
awareness to a case of a set of cases we
work that's one aspect of our work we're
also kind of in consultancy role so any
lawyers or anyone working legal aspect
on on a case may come to us to us
because they may not understand the kind
of Muslim issues the white issues in
certain cases so they may believe
certain things like for instance a
Guantanamo detainee accused as a Shia
and is accused of being al-qaeda which
is not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen it's you know it
doesn't work but for a lawyer would not
know that kind of dynamic until they
come across Muslims of people like
people I asked in cage business I would
tell him look you know this is not going
to happen
Pakistani accused of being a high-level
al-qaeda you know high like high-ranking
enough I didn't what happened you know
there's a certain hierarchy and amongst
Muslims unfortunately but Pakistanis not
up there you know it is one of Yavin
Arab in that way so you know we work in
that consultancy and then obviously some
people will come to us having some
issues harassment by the security
services and so forth and
you know we referred them to appropriate
lawyers because not all lawyers are the
same they don't all have the same heart
when it comes to this kind of work and
you know we tried to help him to clarify
things to them as well and then we tried
to clarify and the misunderstandings in
the water and kind of the misinformation
is put out there as a counter
and your focus your geographical focuses
is it none of Africa was across the
board it's the whole world
okay this case working for the whole
world yeah you're handling cases
everywhere yeah I'd go everywhere I just
yeah well he's sitting at my desk but
yeah what couldn't be anywhere are you
able to travel or are there still
restriction centers until recently I
wasn't but those restrictions I mean
have been lifted so yeah I should be
able to travel haven't tried it but you
know I they shouldn't be there's nothing
kind of overt that will stop me from
traveling
talked earlier about the differences
between Sunni and Shiah talk about the
diversity of the Muslim community how do
you deal with that diversity in your job
today
how do I deal with the diversity you
know the war on terror doesn't make any
distinction so I don't have to it's that
simple
um on terror doesn't care with you
shouldn't Sunni or Shia whether you're
from one school of thought another way
Sufi or whatever or something whatever
it doesn't care you know the war terror
has a very kind of monolithic view of
Muslims and you're Muslim you Muslim
whether you're practicing or not etc so
when it comes to me the caseworker I I
do over the cases they come to me and
that distinction doesn't have to be made
did you graphic do the geographical
distinctions on a problem it's kind of
you know I would have say a convergence
of policy but you know policies are
similar across the world and you know it
makes my job easy but it's it's kind of
troubling what if we talk now about your
reflections on where you are today and
what has been the long-term effect on
your life well I I had this thinking
that time hills and about five six years
I'm gonna get you know just over and
after five six years I can open that
package and I can start dealing with the
issue this is not a situation I've been
in before but um you know it hasn't been
like that so
I don't know it just seems that you know
that as time goes by I don't know what
it is but maybe it affects me more I
perceive as effective if I effect
anymore you know I've tried to get away
from Guantanamo Bay and try to move on
with my life like I said it doesn't
define me but it's something that I
haven't been able to do and the worst
thing I think is that you know wrong law
has been done to me they could have gone
about it about it in the in a better way
due process you know if you go think
I've done anything wrong you treat it as
a crime and you bring me forth before
court of law and you know I have to face
up to whatever occasions you have based
on evidence but that wasn't done so
wrong has been done to me and an
injustice and that ask you in the scales
always remains and because of that I
cannot move on I don't see that you know
I thought I could move on but I can't
move on that you know and I'm seeing
that the war on terror and the US
administration then they don't know
anytime soon gonna say sorry or change
their waist is going to carry on
stopping me what they're doing and yeah
you know it just it just goes to show
that you know I really don't know what
to say about it but you you've suffered
because of the war on terror you're now
working for people who have suffered who
are suffering rather what what does job
what does justice look like for you
well what would be just will be just in
Islam the the Sharia we have our laws
very close to the law of Moses his eye
for an eye tooth for tooth I don't I
really don't believe in anything like a
superstructure or you know when you say
the state or you know the state did this
or an administration it's not I believe
in collectives of people you know
they're like a cooperative there's
collectors of people and they were
collectives of people who decided to do
what they did to me and justice is that
the same thing is done to them it's that
simple
I for an eye tooth for tooth the only
justice there is the Sharia law and
really Guantanamo Bay showed me that I
wasn't wrong and going to go into
Afghanistan I wasn't wrong and going to
want to live under the Sharia
I wasn't barber I though you know I
wasn't treated badly under Sharia well I
was treated badly on the Western law
gone Simon Levay that's a lot of streets
none and you know justice to me Sharia
and those people brought it to actually
a quote and then you know they get their
comeuppance and I hope that I for an eye
tooth for tooth the Muslim community
International on the walk of the war on
terror you know that this I'll say two
worldviews but in someone probably
dispute vien and say but I'll say these
two worldviews you know the there's the
view that the 21st century is the
American Century and then there's a view
that the 21st century is Izanami century
we lost a leaf in 1924 I believe that by
2024 we'll get it back and then the war
on terror what it's done is unified
Muslims because to me
Islam wouldn't have unified the Muslims
as long as there's no one single
Authority while the cat's away the mice
will play
people would just say what they want
they will do what they want and then
they'll say oh I'm good person and so
forth the only thing that unified the
Muslims is the emnity of our enemies and
that's the hate of our enemies is your
anything
unified us and sometimes I've been
surprised by the things that Bush has
done and Obama have done to the point I
think to myself you know are they
secretly most amor something that this
is the only way they've you know the
policies that are putting forth is
unifying the Muslims and then the result
will be Khalifa I really believe that
the Islamic Emirate of Afghanistan what
was you know a false tone and you know
the darkness off the force tone is
always darker than light itself but the
result is it's gonna be Felicia and that
that is the future and now maybe wrong
maybe 2024 so forth but that's my hope
that this century Islamic century and
Islam will come back as a political
power in the world are after being in
nearly 100 years not being that power
other people have different viewpoint I
think and work is going to be you know
the predominant power and American
hegemony American Empire is gonna be you
know predominant in the future I don't
believe that can you read that in the
events of Egypt yeah yeah the thing is
that um the Prophet enormous our enemies
prophesized the future obviously we
can't no one can pinpoint his recon
pinpoint of the date so I say 2024 but
that's just to me it's just my opinion
it doesn't mean anything but he said I
can't remember in the narration he said
that you know you have the the righteous
Khalifa and then after that I Kermit is
something and then there will be kings
and then there will be dictators and
half the dictators there'll be the
righteous Khalifa again the period we
were in his dictators and then it
doesn't say that it would go to anything
else except the righteous Khalifa so you
know the dictators in the in the Middle
East they haven't been removed because
you know it's not Sharia law being
applied there but it's a good sign that
you know in the 1990s and so forth all
we had was dictators but we never saw
any any end to it
we know that the righteous Khalifa will
come but he may not be in our lifetime
now what we're seeing is is the
unification of Muslims and you know
maybe the call is not toward Sharia and
Islam but
to step in that direction
the pasta oh yes professor yeah thank
you all right thank you so much for this
okay
you